Und das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
So, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
So, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss.
So Leute, ich bin auch mal wieder da, hat ein paar Tage gedauert, aber ich habe ein bisschen Anlaufschwierigkeiten gehabt auf der Arbeit.
Ich meine, wenn man umsteigt von ungefähr um halb zehn zehn aufstehen zu um fünfunddreißig aufstehen, also quasi vier bis fünf Stunden später, dann ist man ziemlich im Arsch, das kann ich euch sagen.
Um nicht zu sagen huge im Arsch.
Na eher nicht, eher der hier. Also das ist wirklich anstrengend gewesen, den konnte ich jetzt auch erstmal nicht streben, das war mir zu, ich war zu kaputt abends.
Aber jetzt geht's wieder, jetzt habe ich mich dran gewöhnt und ich spiele immer noch mit dem Gedanke tatsächlich noch weniger zu arbeiten, also stundenmäßig.
Einfach weil ich es kohlemäßig nicht unbedingt nötig habe und umso mehr man Zeit hat für das, wo man Bock drauf hat, umso besser.
Ich meine, wenn du irgendwann mal den Löffel abgibst, erstens sagt keiner, hätte ich mal mehr gearbeitet.
Und außerdem kannst du dich dann freuen, dass du so oft, wie du konntest, das machen durftest, konntest, was du gerne machst.
Das ist doch eigentlich optimal für alle.
Wollen wir mal gucken, ob ich das mache, ich weiß noch nicht genau.
Muss ich mir erstmal überlegen lassen, äh überlegen lassen. Ja Chat, überlegt mal für mich.
Hi IQ Chat, überlegt mal für mich.
Ich wollte euch übrigens mal was richtig Nices zeigen.
Ein nicer Feind, den ich auf Kickstarter gemacht habe.
Und zwar, nicht das Zeug, was die mir da empfehlen, keine Ahnung, was das alles ist.
Ich wollte gerade mal genau gucken, wie es hieß, ich habe mir das aufgeschrieben irgendwo.
Muss ich ja auch mal ein Notizprogramm aufmachen. Der Kiyokone ist da.
Ja, genau, so hieß das. Und zwar habe ich auf Kickstarter gefunden.
BDO oder so, wie spricht man das aus? MEDO? Wie auch immer, zumindest.
Es ist ein Projekt, was sich zum Ziel gesetzt hat, und das haben auch ganz schön viele gebacked.
Was sich zum Ziel gesetzt hat, eine.NET Implementierung für Microcontroller zu...
Also beides, eine.NET Implementierung für Microcontroller zu basteln und ein Board zu basteln, worauf das ganze läuft.
Und die Versprechungen sind echt nice, allerdings wissen wir ja.
Kickstarter Kampagne und Versprechen und das, was am Ende rauskommt, deckt sich nicht unbedingt immer.
Ich denke an diese ganzen, an diesen ganzen Scams, wie sie mich da zum Beispiel mit der einen Hose gescampt haben.
Das ärgert mich heute noch auf Kickstarter.
Es ist noch ein bisschen, merke ich es im Hals hinten, aber ich bin gar nicht wirklich so richtig krank geworden.
Mir hat bloß der Hals wehgetan. Normalerweise tut einem der Hals zwei Tage weh und dann kriegt man Erkältung oder so.
Das ist jetzt immer noch ein bisschen, aber ich kann wieder ordentlich labern.
Ich war aber vor allem ziemlich kaputt, aber natürlich wieder angefangen abzuarbeiten.
Aber wie gesagt, es gab ja so viel Scam.
Was für eine Hose.
Passt mal auf, das ist Kickstarter Scam Hose.
Kickstarter Silver Jeans.
Die selbst reinigende Jeans, die habe ich damals gebacked.
Das ist eine, ich backe nicht so viel auf Kickstarter, aber das ist eine Sache, wo ich komplett gescampt wurde.
Da wurde ich komplett gescampt.
Ich habe hier noch ein ziemlich hohes Tier genommen.
Das habe ich nicht genommen.
Entweder habe ich das genommen, zwei T-Shirts.
Ich habe Hose und zwei T-Shirts oder so etwas genommen.
Wie viel Kohle?
Man und Frau.
Ich habe das mit Shirt.
Gibt es das Original Tier vielleicht nicht mehr?
Ich glaube, das Original, die Original Tiers gibt es nicht mehr.
Ich habe eins genommen mit, ich glaube, auf jeden Fall eine Jeans und ich glaube, zwei Shirts.
Es könnte aber auch nur ein Shirt gewesen sein.
Ich glaube, ich habe 150 Dollar oder so geplatscht.
Und funktioniert überhaupt nicht.
Ne, noch schlimmer, noch schlimmer.
Ich habe es nie gekriegt.
Richtiges Scamas.
Mal gucken, was das letzte Update war.
Da muss ich mal gucken.
16. 2018, ja.
Siehst du, und die Leute haben nicht geschrieben, vor allem hier,
Comments to Like Ratio, ja, es ist voll von Arsch.
Feedback Request, so ein Scamas, Alter, Feedback Request.
Die haben die Dinger nie losgeschickt.
Und im letzten Post, mit dem wir uns jetzt leider nicht angucken können, weil ich nicht eingeloggt bin,
im letzten, ich mache mal kurz Kirby ein bisschen.
Zu viel, zu viel Happy Kirby Musik.
Calming and Relaxing.
Sehr gut.
Da ist es jetzt.
Ah.
So.
Und Five Way Bouts.
Leute, ich mache jetzt mal den Trick, den ich auf der Arbeit auch immer bringe.
Ich bin dran.
Ich habe einen Sub verpasst, tatsächlich.
Der Tribulon hat subscribt.
Nice Sub.
Twitch Prime, Big Prime, Big Brain, Big Prime Sub.
Die Emotes kommen, die Emotes, die kommen dann, wenn es dieses Amazon,
wir schauen zusammen Serienprogramm, auch für Deutschland gibt.
Kannst du auch eine Mode einführen für Leute, die cheeren?
Äh, wieso, hä?
Verstehe ich nicht.
Wir schauen dann.
Kann ich euch sagen, sollte jemals, wie auch immer das hieß,
Watch Parties, sollte jemals das hier in Deutschland kommen,
dass man Amazonsachen auf Twitch gucken kann.
Das erste, was wir uns zusammen angucken, ist Mr. Robot.
Wir gucken uns Mr. Robot die erste Staffel an.
Und ich werde sie flamen, wie krass sie es verkackt haben.
Ich fand, ich habe nur die erste Staffel Mr. Robot geguckt.
Ich war so enttäuscht von der zweiten Hälfte der ersten Staffel,
die ich keinen Bock hatte.
Ich habe mir nichts mehr danach angeguckt, Mr. Robot.
Ich fand, Mr. Robot war am Anfang, also die erste Hälfte der ersten Staffel,
richtig gut.
Das hatte halbwegs für Fernsehverhältnisse fundierten technischen Hintergrund.
Und das war spannend gemacht.
Staffel 8? Ach so, nee.
Ich rede jetzt von Mr. Robot.
Von dem anderen Gramm fange ich jetzt gar nicht an.
Und ich war so enttäuscht, dass es quasi ab der zweiten Hälfte der ersten Staffel
weder um irgendwelche technischen Sachen ging,
noch um die eigentlichen Hackgeschichten, mit denen das Ganze angefangen hat,
noch irgendwie um irgendwas Interessantes.
Es ging bloß noch um den Dachschaden, den er hält hat.
Und das fand ich bei Mr. Robot echt schlecht gelungen,
zumal die sich es auch richtig versaut haben.
Die haben...
Ich habe ja bis zur letzten Folge darauf gehofft,
dass die noch die Kurve kriegen.
Ich habe es gehofft bis zur letzten Folge.
Da habe ich gedacht, okay, das ist alles so build-up,
so ein bisschen wie bei der Witcher Serie,
die mich auch von der ersten Folge echt nicht begeistert hat.
Aber ich hoffe, dass es noch gut wird.
Kann ich gleich noch was zu sagen.
Aber zumindest, was sie halt übelst verkackt haben bei Mr. Robot ist...
Wartet mal kurz.
Ich brauche ein bisschen Wum-Wum-Entspannungszeug jetzt.
Genau.
Was sie bei Mr. Robot meiner Meinung nach in dem Staffelfinale übelst verkackt haben ist...
Die haben ja bis dahin den...
Ich habe Tyrell hieße, oder?
Tyrell war der Typ aus Game of Thrones.
Wie hieß denn der?
Der CTO.
Dude.
Mr. Robot.
Doch Tyrell, der hieß Tyrell.
Ja, Spoil.
Alter, wann ist Mr. Robot rausgekommen?
Das ist 2015?
Ja?
Was jetzt?
Ernsthaft?
Choose my name.
Big Prime sub, huge.
Sehr schön, danke.
Zumindest, um jetzt mal zu dem Punkt zu kommen, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte.
Es gab ja ein paar Charaktere und es ging zwar am Anfang um Hexerzeug oder nicht mehr so.
Aber ich fand die Story um diesen CTO-Typ, diesen Tyrell, fand ich noch ganz okay.
Und du hast dich alles gefragt, was ist denn da jetzt, was ist denn passiert?
Und die haben dazu die ganze finale Folge nichts gesagt.
Nichts.
Also die ganze Staffel Mr. Robot, die erste, hat ja darauf hingearbeitet, dass sie quasi,
ich sag jetzt mal so spoilerfrei wie es geht, quasi so die Welt hacken.
So die großen Konzerne, Hexoren und das irgendwie so ein neues Zeitalter der krassen Hexor anbricht.
So ungefähr.
War ja die Story von Mr. Robot.
Nee, nicht die Story von Mr. Robot.
Was die Hexorkruppe aus Mr. Robot wollte.
Und die haben nur die ganze Staffel darauf hingearbeitet.
Und am Ende ist dann das Ereignis eingetreten, was die ganze Staffel darauf hingearbeitet wurde.
Und man hat absolut nichts draus gemacht, die letzte Folge.
Und nachdem ich die zweite Hälfte schon zu gestört fand, was den Held anbelangt,
also so nach dem Motto, der hat es halt nicht mehr alle.
Das habe ich dann irgendwann auch verstanden.
Und die letzte Folge so verkackt war, dass quasi der große Hack nichts ausgelöst hat
und man die CTO-Story nicht mal ansatzweise irgendwie weitergeführt hat.
Da war ich so enttäuscht, dass ich gerade mehr gucke mit ihm an.
Wir haben von Anfang an auf mehrere Staffeln geschrieben.
Nichtsdestotrotz muss man schauen, dass das irgendwie eine gewisse Spannungsbohrung hat
und eine gewisse Konsistenz hat auch in einer Staffel.
Ich weiß.
Deswegen, ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich mir die zweite Staffel Mr. Robot angucken soll.
Das ist jetzt ja auch schon ein bisschen her.
Kam mir in 2016.
Aber nachdem ich gelesen habe, es fokussiert sich noch mehr darauf, dass der Held sie nicht mehr alle hat,
habe ich mir gedacht, ne, Staffel 3 und 4 sind gut.
Mag sein, aber ganz ehrlich, wenn man von der zweiten Hälfte oder generell vom Ende
und der zweiten Hälfte von Staffel 1 schon enttäuscht war,
Staffel 2 einen überhaupt nicht angesprochen hat von dem, was man gelesen hat,
dann guckt, es mag sein, dass die besser sind, aber dann guckt man sich das nicht an.
Übrigens, Leute.
Ich wollte übrigens hier noch was zu sagen, aber...
Ich habe jetzt ein bisschen The Witcher geguckt.
Ja.
Es ist ja ein unglaublicher Hype mittlerweile um diese Serie entstanden.
Natürlich ganz klar, weil die durch die Spiele schon viele Fans hatten vorher.
Ich glaube, es ist in dem Fall nicht so wie bei Game of Thrones oder auch bei Herr der Ringe früher,
dass halt viele Leute da sind, die die Bücher gespielt haben.
Die Witcher Serie ist durch die Spiele richtig bekannt geworden.
Die Bücher gibt es schon länger, aber ich weiß es nicht,
aber ich glaube mal, die Bücher waren nie der riesen finanzielle Erfolg
und auch nie der große internationale Erfolg vorher.
Das Witcher auf 480p, ja.
Aber die Spiele haben es halt irgendwie groß gemacht.
Ich meine, wenn es eine riesen Serie gewesen wäre,
hätte er nicht die Rechte, was die Bücher gespielt haben.
Macht ihr das nicht.
Zumindest, wenn es sonst eine riesen Erfolg gewesen wäre,
hätte er nicht für ein Apple und ein iD Rechte an CD Projekt Red verkauft.
Für was hat er die Witcher Rechte damals verkauft?
Ich sage jetzt einfach mal 1000 Dollar.
Es war nichts im Endeffekt.
Also das spricht nicht jetzt für eine wahnsinnig finanziell erfolgreiche Sache.
Was ich gut finde, muss ich sagen,
also was mir richtig gut gefällt, ich spoilere jetzt auch nicht, keine Sorge.
Also ich werde nichts großartiges erzählen.
Ich habe noch nicht viel geguckt, nur die ersten paar Sachen.
Ja genau, Knerbeer.
Das fordert er jetzt, nachdem die Witcher Spiele so wahnsinnig erfolgreich waren.
Das fordert er jetzt.
Er hat es ursprünglich für ein Apple und ein i verkauft.
Also ich habe natürlich mitgekriegt, dass es Zeitsprünge gibt da drin.
Es ist auch relativ eindeutig, dass die Serie Story quasi,
das ich euch jetzt misst, erzähle, nach dem Spiel, also am Anfang zumindest,
wo man Geralt sieht, da wird auch ein paar Mal darauf Bezug genommen.
Mir ist doch schon klar, dass das mehr oder weniger parallel läuft.
Allerdings muss ich sagen, ohne zu spoilern,
ich finde, sie machen es sich teilweise ein bisschen zu einfach.
Die Dialoge zünden nicht so richtig.
Es wird auch ein bisschen wenig erklärt, muss man sagen.
Ich meine, ich kenne von den Büchern nur der letzte Wunsch
und das auch nur als Hörbuch, also das hier.
Das ist die erste, das ist glaube ich die allererste Kurzgeschichtensammlung,
die es so aus dem Witcher Universum gab.
Das habe ich mir irgendwann bei Audible als Hörbuch geholt,
eine Weile nachdem ich die Spiele gespielt habe, fand ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Aber man muss ja sagen, das hat ja nichts mit dem aus den Spielen zu tun.
Das ist ja komplett losgelöst davon so ein bisschen.
Und das Problem ist, ich finde, sie machen sich das teilweise ein bisschen einfach.
Gar nicht so sehr, weil sie Sachen, die später überraschend sein sollen,
was die nicht erklärt werden, das ist okay.
Es braucht immer eine gesunde Mischung aus, dass man der Sache folgen kann
und dass man quasi schon so eine Vorahnung hat, was sein könnte.
Ich meine, guckt euch mal an, jetzt bis es mit Game of Thrones total verkackt haben,
aber wie viele Fan-Theorien es auch zu den Büchern damals schon gegeben hat bei Game of Thrones.
Wer könnte der Vater sein und was weiß ich, was passiert mit dem...
Egal, alles mögliche, gab es ganz viele Theorien.
Also sprich, da sieht man schon, das beschäftigt die Leute.
Das heißt, es ist wichtig, dass man im Vorfeld schon so ein paar Sachen
in die Geschichte streut, wo man dann quasi das revealen kann
und clevere Leute sind schon vorher auf die Idee gekommen.
Die Sache ist plus die, dass ich den Eindruck habe, dass sie das eben nicht machen
und ich beziehe mich jetzt nicht auf so offensichtliche Sachen,
wie dass es unterschiedliche Zeitstränge hat,
sondern zum Beispiel sieht man, ich sage jetzt nicht, was passiert,
man sieht Ciri und ihre Oma, habe ich ja gestern auf Twitter schon geschrieben.
Man sieht Ciri und ihre Oma und die Ciri-Story, die ist in der ersten Folge,
da ist kein Zeitsprung in dem Sinn.
Am Ende, vielleicht, muss man mal gucken, aber der Anfang ist kontinuierlich nacheinander.
Eindeutig ist der nacheinander, weil Szene 1 und Szene 2 und 3 und 4,
die Folgen hatten nun mal aufeinander, direkt vom Ablauf her
und es wird auf der Szene dann nach Bezug genommen, direkt auf nie was davor passiert ist.
Also da gibt es keine Zeitsprünge am Anfang.
Das wollten mir die Leute ja gestern auf Twitter erzählen.
Ich habe jetzt auch ein bisschen weiter geguckt.
Es ist relativ offensichtlich, was welche Zeit ist,
aber am Anfang ist es halt einfach nur für nicht schlecht erzählt.
Zum Beispiel, es wird absolut nicht schlüssig erklärt,
warum die sich so dämlich bei der Verteidigung von der Stadt anstellen.
Und es wird auch absolut nicht erklärt,
wie die Oma es schafft, da irgendwie immer in der richtigen Szene am richtigen Ort zu sein.
Das wird absolut nicht erklärt.
Die Oma ist immer zur richtigen Zeit am richtigen Ort.
Das ist quasi für das, was sie jetzt sagen wollen, passt irgendwie.
Erst ist sie beim Essen, dann ist sie in der Schlacht
und dann ist sie von der Schlacht wieder im Schloss zurück.
Und da frage ich mich, ist sie irgendwie über Schallgeschwindigkeit schnell, die Oma?
Ich meine, sie werden angegriffen, okay?
Sie werden angegriffen, so die Oma ist mitten in der Schlacht
und dann ist sie vor den Angreifern wieder im Schloss.
Wie soll das dann funktionieren?
Sie hat auch keine Rüstung mehr an oder so.
Sie spawnt die Oma, wenn ihr die Serie guckt,
und die Oma im Schloss seht, denkt dran, das wirkt so,
als ist die Oma in diesem Moment auf dem Sofa gespawnt,
wo Siri in den Raum reinkommt.
So genau so wirkt das.
So komplett Sprung von einem, das ist kein Zeitsprung.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Also wenn sie das mit der Verteidigung noch erklären,
ich kann nicht alles verstehen, aber ich gehe auch davon aus,
dass sie noch ein paar Lücken füllen werden.
Aber manche Sachen sind einfach vom Ablauf irgendwie faul.
Als hätten sie keinen Bock gehabt, ja.
Und was das mit Geralt und dem einen Mädel im Wald soll,
ich weiß nicht so genau.
Das war eher cringe als was man da...
Viele, viele Sachen.
Die Hintergrundgeschichte von dem Mädel wird auch nicht richtig erklärt.
Ich meine jetzt nicht Siri, ich meine die andere.
Wird auch nicht richtig erklärt.
Komisch.
Also es ist an vielen Stellen irgendwie so gespart.
Also mit gespart meine ich jetzt nicht,
dass sie irgendwie an Budget gespart haben,
sondern dass sie an Zeit vom Drehbuch gespart haben oder so.
Also es ist nicht bis jetzt nicht so der große Wurf,
wie man sich das vorgestellt hat.
Aber leider, muss man sagen, ist Netflix ja irgendwie auch dafür bekannt,
dass Netflix nicht sagt, wir machen das Bestmögliche,
sondern das haben Netflix schon oft genug gesagt,
wir machen das, was preisleistungsmäßig für uns das meiste bringt.
Ja, also, Rest, also ich überlege gerade,
vielleicht mache ich auch ein abschließendes Fazit,
wenn die Serie rum ist.
Wir könnten übrigens mal Deep in Linux downloaden in der Zwischenzeit.
Vielleicht mache ich ein abschließendes Fazit Video irgendwie,
wenn das fertig ist.
Also die China Linux, da müssen wir uns aufpassen.
Oh, oh, man kann sich eine ISO runterladen über Mega.
Mega, falls sich da jemand auch dran erinnern kann.
Upload to me today, Mega-Upload.
Oder von der Baidu Cloud kann man das Ganze auch laden.
Warte mal kurz, ganz kurz.
Nur mal so, nur mal den Anfang, okay?
Nur mal den Anfang.
Die hatten so keinen flassen Schimmer,
auf was sie sich da einlassen bei dem Video.
Ist so geil.
Man sieht es denen auch schon so richtig an.
Da ist irgendein Marketing-Mensch zu denen hingegangen
und haben gesagt, sag mal Mega-Upload in die Kamera.
Die hatten so keinen Plan, um was es da geht.
Wer ist das?
Die anderen kenne ich, aber wer ist das?
Nee, den kenne ich auch nicht.
Wer ist das?
Okay, ich kenne die doch nicht alle.
Ich kenne eigentlich nur zwei.
War das nicht der Boxer?
Ah, das kann sein, ja.
Nee, der Erste war hier, der West.
Okay, Leute, das reicht.
Genug Mega-Upload.
Danke schön, drei Monate.
Das ist ja halt selbst.
Internet.
Das war 2011, das gab es ja dann schon eine Weile.
So, jetzt haben wir immer noch kein ISO runtergeladen.
Mirrors.
Okay, wo kann man hier was runterladen?
Ah, nee, hier CD.
Releases.
15.9.
15.9 ist das letzte, glaube ich mal.
Da ist es, damn.
Oh, Mist, Leute, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, Moment, wartet mal.
Ah, okay.
Das könnte knapp werden.
Das könnte, das könnte knapp werden.
Muss man mal gucken, wie viel das braucht.
Ähm, nee.
15.10 gibt es noch nicht, oder?
Oder doch?
Nee, das ist was anderes.
Hä?
Moment.
Wartet mal.
Was ist das für ein Schwachsinn?
Hä?
Okay, wir haben das falsche.
Wir haben das falsche.
Scamas.
15.11.
Okay, Download.
Warum ist es im ISO, warum ist es in ihrem ISO-Repo nicht drin?
Official Release.
Live.
Live-System.
Deep in Live.
What?
Was muss das?
Mega.
Google Drive.
Ah, okay.
Also, man kann, man kann es eher von Google Drive runterladen,
anstatt, anstatt vom offiziellen Kedas.
Das schafft schon, das schafft schon wieder sehr viel Vertrauen in die ganze Geschichte.
Hätten wir das mal lieber beim Mega-Upload hochgeladen,
dann hätten wir uns den Mega-Upload-Song jetzt anhören können.
Ja, und also, um das mal zu beenden mit der Witcher-Serie, wir müssen mal abwarten.
Also, die erste, die ersten paar Sachen haben mich nicht, nicht 100% überzeugt.
Vor allem, weil ich halt irgendwo allergisch dagegen bin,
wenn Sachen so versucht werden zu kaschieren.
Ich habe nichts dagegen, wenn man in einer Story die Sachen nicht alle zeigt, ja.
Weil ansonsten wäre ja jeder Film zu 90% Charaktere laufen von einem Ort zum anderen.
Das ist natürlich blödsinnig, ja.
Aber man sollte einfach das irgendwie honorieren,
dass man vorher was aufgebaut hat, was man jetzt auch erklären muss.
Zum Beispiel, es würde voll und ganz ausreichen, wenn quasi jemand fliehen muss
und man möchte die Flucht nicht zeigen, sondern man möchte mit der Story weitermachen,
dass derjenige dann einfach irgendwie sagt, oh, das war knapp, sie sind mir auf den Fersen.
Irgendwie sowas, easy.
Dann weißt du, er ist knapp geflohen und die anderen sind hinter ihm her.
Alles gut, so kann man das Story technisch machen, aber nicht,
hallo, ich bin wieder da. Ohne was. War nichts, ich bin wieder da.
Nicht der Redewert, nicht der Redewert, es ist nichts passiert.
Das finde ich, das ist dann einfach faul von Drehbuchschreibern gewesen, wenn man das so macht.
Okay, deep in, da haben wir es.
Max Werth auch Writer. Zu schlechtes Englisch, zu schlechtes Deutsch.
Wenn ich in C-Sharp oder in einer anderen Programmiersprache writen könnte, dann vielleicht eher.
Ach ja, bevor wir die VM anlegen, wollte ich euch ja noch was fertig zeigen.
Und zwar, wir sind ein bisschen side-tracked worden wieder.
Genau, also das mit der Jeans hatten wir abgehakt, da haben sie mich halt gescampt um 150 Euro.
Von welcher Szene sprichst du jetzt?
Das ist das, was ich gestern auch auf Twitter geschrieben habe,
das ist sowas, womit es halt besonders aufgefallen ist, aber es gab noch mehr Szenen.
Wonach der Schlacht die Oma einfach wieder im Schloss war.
So als wäre, so als, als, sie ist einfach auf dem Sofa gesporn, wo Siri reingekommen ist.
Ohne Rüstung, die war vorher in der Schlacht, mitten den Gegnern.
Und auf einmal ist sie auf dem Sofa.
Das sehe ich jetzt nicht so als Probleme, ich schon.
Ich finde das verdirbt einfach so die Atmosphäre und Stimmung, wenn sowas nicht erklärt wird.
So, ich wollte euch ja das Ding hier noch zeigen.
Das habe ich mir auch, habe ich nicht gebacked, sondern ich habe mir mal einen vorbestellt,
weil die versuchen einen Microcontroller zu basteln mit, wo.NET 2.0 standard draufläuft.
Und die versprechen hier das Blaue vom Himmel runter.
Ein neues Testament, die können das doch ganz einfach machen.
Das ist, siehst du, die meisten Leute denken, finde ich, zu kurz, wenn es um so Storygeschichten geht.
Die meisten Leute denken dann so nach dem Motto, ja ich will doch nicht sehen, wie die nach Hause geschleift wird.
Ich will doch nicht sehen, was das ist.
Ich will nicht, dass die mir das alles noch mal erklären.
Müssen sie gar nicht.
Es ist einfach nur wichtig, dass man, wie ich eben gesagt habe, dass man das irgendwie honoriert, was da drumherum passiert.
Weil ansonsten wirkt das einfach, wie als hättest du den Charakter gespawnt im Endeffekt.
Und nicht als wäre das ein Charakter in der Geschichte.
Es reicht voll und ganz, wenn die Oma gesagt hätte, knapp entkommen, sie sind uns auf den Fersen.
Solche Szenen gibt es auch im Game ja und macht es besser.
Nur weil es bei dem einen kacke ist und beim anderen auch kacke, muss es ja nicht, dann macht es es ja nicht irgendwie besser.
Es hätte voll und ganz gereicht, ja.
Es hätte voll und ganz gereicht oder hätte die Wache, hätte die Wache Ciri in den Raum geführt oder so.
Und hätte gesagt, wir sind knapp entkommen, eurer Großmutter geht das nicht.
Irgendwas, ja.
Das hätte 10 Sekunden, 15 Sekunden der Zeit, hätte das in Anspruch genommen.
Und es hätte dafür gesorgt, dass es sich eben anfühlt, als ist das ein richtiger Charakter in dieser Welt.
Und nicht, ich bin jetzt auf dem Sofa gespawnt, weil ich Ciri's Plot weiter vorantreiben muss.
Das ist einfach faul, ist meine Ansicht zu dieser Sache.
Und ich bin da bei sowas halt auch sehr pingelig, muss ich sagen.
Ich bin da sehr pingelig und bin da auch sehr allergisch dagegen.
Vor allem, wo ich auch immer, aber wie gesagt, ich bin bei sowas auch pingelig.
Ich finde es immer blöd, wenn sich Leute in Filmserien so komplett unsinnig verhalten.
Also ohne, ohne dass es die Situation erfordert.
Gibt es weitaus Schlimmeres, das war jetzt ein Beispiel.
Es gibt viele, das summiert sich ja mit der Zeit.
Es summiert sich, es sind viele so Kleinigkeiten.
Und ich finde, das passt einfach nicht.
Das wird der Sache auch nicht gerecht.
Man macht ja eine gute Vorlage.
Und ich finde es immer blöd, wenn die Leute sich so komplett unlogisch, unpassend verhalten.
Ich meine, warum würde das?
Leute, ihr seid so unkreativ.
Ihr seid so unkreativ.
Das war ein Beispiel.
Die Oma muss das nicht zu Ciri sagen.
Das ist egal.
Das kann die Oma auch.
Das kann auch eine Wache.
Das kann auch eine Wache zur Oma.
Es ist vollkommen egal.
Es geht einfach darum, dass man quasi anerkennt, was drum herum passiert.
Dass man nicht einfach nur auf einmal wieder da ist und nur die drei Sätze sagt, die jetzt für die Handlung wichtig sind.
Weil sobald man das macht, heißt das im Endeffekt, ich bin nur dazu da, um Ciri's Plot voranzutreiben und bin eigentlich sonst komplett unsinnig.
So.
Das wirkt halt einfach nicht stimmig.
Man hätte auch, es gibt so viele Möglichkeiten, was man hätte machen können.
Du hättest auch kurz irgendwie was einspielen können.
Oder, keine Ahnung, die Oma hätte sich die Stufen draufschleppen.
Irgendwas.
Aber nicht einfach von der Schlacht in Rüstung mit 1.000 Gegner an der Front spawnen auf dem Sofa in der Festung ohne Rüstung.
Da ist einfach, und dann nichts zu dem ganzen Ding irgendwie sagen.
Das ist einfach faul.
Anders kann ich das nicht nennen.
Man darf auch nicht immer so unkreativ sein und sich das Direkteste überlegen.
Hätten sie es mal gezeigt?
Hätten sie mal das irgendwie?
Da noch ein paar Dialoge.
Es gibt so viele Möglichkeiten, quasi das ordentlich in die Welt einzubauen, sodass sich Charaktere eben nicht anfühlen, als wurden sie einfach aufgestellt, um jetzt an dieser Stelle die eine Sache zu machen, ansonsten braucht man sie nicht.
Nee, es geht nicht um die Timeskips.
Die sind sogar noch halbwegs verständlich.
Die, finde ich, an manchen Stellen ein bisschen schlechter Erzählweise.
Ein bisschen fauler Erzählweise.
So als hätten sie keinen Bock gehabt, da irgendwie noch eine Dialogzeile hinzuschreiben.
Ich finde, das verdirbt auch so ein bisschen die Stimmung.
Und genau.
Eine Sache, die ich halt auch immer blöd finde, ist, wenn sich Charaktere in Spielen, Serien, Filmen, ist das eigentlich vollkommen egal, komplett unlogisch verhalten.
Und ich meine jetzt nicht, dass man, dass Menschen nicht was unlogisches tun, das macht man laufend, sondern dass es in der Umwelt von diesem Spiel, Film, Serie halt irgendwie keinen Sinn ergibt.
Zum Beispiel, das ist auch so was, wo wir jetzt mal wieder Witcher als Beispiel nehmen können.
Sie müssen ja die Stadt verteidigen am Anfang.
Wie gesagt, ich gebe mir Mühe, ich könnte das noch viel genauer erklären, aber ich will jetzt nicht wirklich großartig spoilern.
Sie müssen eine Stadt verteidigen und sie haben eine Festung.
Und besser gesagt, die Stadt ist befestigt.
In der Stadt steht eine Festung.
So.
Warum verteidigt man sich nicht in einer Festung?
Man hat eine Festung.
Was meint, was meint ihr denn, wofür werden denn Burgen gebaut im Mittelalter?
Bestimmt nicht, um sich vor dem Tor die Köppe einzuschlagen, dass der Gewinner die Festung claimen kann.
Weil Magic, ja.
Und man hatte ja offensichtlich genug Zeit, die Oma hochzuschleppen, wieder auf Sofa zu legen, die Rüstung auszuziehen.
Und alles gut.
In der Zwischenzeit hätte man vielleicht genau ein neues Testament.
Das ist auch wieder so was.
Also wenn die die Szene so aus dem Buch genommen haben und es im Buch keinerlei Erklärungen dazu gegeben hat, ist es doof geschrieben, genauso wie die Serie.
Allerdings gehe ich mal stark von aus, es wird im Buch ordentliche Erklärungen drum herum gegeben haben.
Und die muss man einfach, ich mein man hat in dem Film ja auch ein paar Möglichkeiten sowas zu machen.
Die muss man einfach kurz, es reichen eins, zwei Sätze, muss man einfach erklären.
Sonst wirkt das Ganze nicht stimmig und einfach so wie Aufsteller hingestellt, du musst jetzt halt das sagen, damit das passiert.
Und das ist einfach faul.
Es ist genau so, es ist ungefähr auf dem gleichen Level wie eine MMO-Quest.
Und es kann mir keiner erzählen, dass MMO-Quests jetzt irgendwie eine super storytechnische Tiefe haben, die meisten.
Es gibt sehr gute Quests, aber die meisten MMO-Quests in der Richtung so.
Oh Hilfe, ich habe den Hochzeitstag vergessen meiner Verlobten und ich brauche jetzt 15 Blumen.
Dann gehst du mal Blumen sammeln und oh nein, die Verlobte, die ist ja irgendwie jetzt untot und auf dem Friedhof.
Und da musst du ja noch den Ring holen und so.
Einfach nur Dinge passieren zu lassen, damit andere Dinge weitergehen.
Das ist einfach, das ist faul.
Das muss die ganze Sache nicht schlecht machen, das zerstört irgendwie die Stimmung.
Und mit unsinnig verhalten meine ich halt auch zum Beispiel, man kann sich ja, man muss sich auch, wenn man eine,
auch wenn man ein Fantasy Buch schreibt oder eine Fantasy Serie dreht oder ein Spiel in irgendeinem Fantasyuniversum macht,
es gelten ja gewisse Regeln.
Diese Regeln müssen irgendwie etabliert werden.
Ansonsten hast du so ein bisschen wie in Herr der Ringe, wo eigentlich keiner so genau weiß, was Gandalf für ein Typ ist.
Ich weiß, man kann, ich rede jetzt nur von, nur von, wenn man Herr der Ringe gelesen hat.
Also keine Ahnung, kann der jetzt gut, ist er jetzt der übelst krasse Zauberer, da zaubert er kaum, warum zaubert er eigentlich kaum
und was kann er alles und wie möchte, weißt du bei Herr der Ringe alles nicht so genau.
Man kann sich natürlich da mit 20 Millionen Sachen drumherum beschäftigen,
da kommt man dann schon irgendwie dahinter, dahinter, dass Gandalf quasi so eine Art Mini-Gott ist.
Aber das weiß man nicht, das heißt, das muss man irgendwie erklären.
Und man muss sich auch, nachdem es Regeln in einer Fantasywelt geben muss und es muss Regeln geben,
weil ansonsten artet das aus wie in manchen, wie in manchen Anime-Fights,
so nach dem Motto, ich zünde jetzt meine Ultra-Power 2, haha, aber ich habe eine Ultra-Power 5.
Einfach random, von denen vorher keiner was gehört hat.
Das ist, das ist schlecht.
Das ist halt, das ist halt, das ist halt un, billig, ja, im Endeffekt.
Und deswegen gelten ja auch in einer Fantasywelt gewisse, gewisse Regeln, die muss man erklären.
Und wenn man eine mittelalterlich bezogene, sagen wir jetzt mal,
nicht, nicht gänzlich abgedrehte, unrealistische Fantasywelt etabliert,
ähm, dann muss man sich auch den Vergleich gefallen lassen zum Mittelalter, ja.
Und im Mittelalter wurden Festungen gebaut, dass man sich drinnen verteidigen kann.
Es wurden Stadtmauern gebaut, dass man sich in der Stadt verschanzen kann, verteidigen kann,
weil im Mittelalter war es so, Logistik war, also nicht so wie heute, wo du, ähm, das ist falsch, lol.
Ja, gut, es gibt Leute, die haben sich Festungen später, später, viel später, hingestellt, äh,
weil es schön war, aber die waren dann auch nicht verteidigungsgerecht, ähm, gebaut.
Und es war im Mittelalter, generell bis, bis etwas neuere Zeit, war, war ein, ein, eine Schlacht,
ein Krieg zuführen war ein unglaubliches, logistisches, äh, Aufkommen, ja.
Du hast, du hast nicht damals DHL eingepackt und hast mal irgendwie ne, ne Ration irgendwo hingeschickt oder irgendwie sowas, ja.
Das war ein unglaublich logistischer Aufwand, ist es heute ja im Prinzip auch noch, wenn du kein DHL hast,
womit du es mitschicken kannst, ähm, aber damals war es so, wenn sich jemand in der Burg verschanzt hat,
das war für den, die quasi, nennen wir es mal, belagert wurden, Scheiße, und es war für die Belagerer Scheiße,
weil es hatte kein Mensch Bock, keiner, und, ähm, es gibt auch genug Sachen, wo die abgezogen sind,
es wollte keiner belagern, das war un, unglaublich teuer, du musstest ja da immer deine ganze riesenfette Armee,
Wochen, Monate vor diesem Ding, äh, stationieren, das war, und logistisch war das, du musstest Vorräte dran haben,
das war unglaublich, es wollte niemand belagern, die wollten, die sind, die sind, die sind lieber weitergelaufen,
die sind lieber weitergegangen einfach anstatt, anstatt sie da drinnen, weil es einfach so teuer war,
und damals ist es auch nicht so gewesen wie im Film, dass die, ähm, jetzt ne Armee von 30.000 Leuten hatten,
das war schon nicer fight, wenn das 500 Leute waren, und es wurde auch nicht, ähm, sich in einer Reihe aufgestellt,
und, und, und, und, und hirnlos quasi ineinander gelaufen, ähm, sondern man hat in Formation gekämpft,
deswegen haben die auch alle mit Schwert und, äh, mit, ähm, mit Schild und Speer,
das kann man, sieht, wenn man sich mittelallelige Sachen anguckt, ähm, Aufzeichnungen und, und, äh, sich immer ein bisschen beleast,
kann man dann feststellen, da wurde nicht einfach Köpfe eingerannt, wie das im Film ist, ja, ähm,
da wurde, wenn überhaupt, wurde dort in Formation gekämpft, mit Schild und Speer zum größten Teil,
Kavallerie war gar nicht in der ersten, also Reiter war gar nicht in der ersten Reihe, damit hast du versucht, quasi, äh, äh, Huge Big Brain Movement zu machen,
ähm, es gibt, glaub ich, kein, jaja, das, das ist halt generell, das ist jetzt generell so ein bisschen Rant, wo ich mich halt drüber auslassen kann,
ähm, und, ja, den Vergleich zum Mittelalter muss man sich dann halt gefallen lassen, wenn man, wenn man eine mittelalterlich angehauchte Fantasy-Serien macht,
ja, aber da wollte ich eigentlich gar nicht drauf raus, es sind so viele Sachen, die nicht, die nicht stimmen, ähm,
was König und Königin an der Front machen, ist mir auch komplett unverständlich, ja, ich weiß, es gibt eine Erklärung zu,
dass sie ja quasi so die krasse, ähm, ich bash alles Königin, es gibt, okay, lass ich mir gefallen, aber es ist rein strategisch gesehen, ähm,
es ist rein strategisch gesehen, auch für, auch für einen, der gerne mit draufhaut, strategisch gesehen, unglaublich dumm, ähm,
in der ersten Reihe als Anführer zu stehen, ja, Brain Delay, wir, wir haben es gleich, ja, es ist, wobei Mittelalterliche Herführer haben durchaus,
also doch, das ist untypisch, es sind viele auch in Schlachten umgekommen, das stimmt, aber die, gut, haben sie gemacht, die, die erfolgreich waren,
die haben das aber geschickter gemacht, also es ist vor allem in einer Schlacht, wo man, wo man sieht, wo man sieht, dass der Gegner zahlenmäßig weit überlegen ist,
ich meine, überlegt euch mal, du gehst in die, du, du, du gehst schon mal, man hat sich eh nicht auf den Hügel getroffen oder sowas, man hat eher vorher Scharmützel ausgetragen,
wo ein paar Leute die anderen gepiesagt haben und hin und her und vor große Schlachten hat man eigentlich vermieden, große Schlachten hat man eigentlich eher vermieden,
weil eine große Schlacht immer bedeutet hat, du kannst alles verlieren und bist RIP, ja, deine Armee ist weg und du spawnst nicht einfach mal in echt eine neue Armee, ja, egal,
wie dem auch sei, es ist halt unrealistisch, ja, und zumal der, der, der, wirklich, also man muss, man muss kein, man muss kein, man muss kein Big Brain sein, um auf die Idee zu kommen,
wenn man auf einem Hügel steht und vor sich sieht, dass der Gegner massig viel mehr Truppen hat, ja, und hinter einem ist die Stadt mit Stadtmauern und einer Festung drinne,
da muss man nicht wirklich sonderlich Big Brain sein, um auf die Idee zu kommen, Leute, wie wäre es einfach mit umdrehen und in die Stadtmauer gehen, oder?
Da waren viele eins versus eins Kämpfe früher, nein, waren sie nicht, Schlachten früher waren Formationskämpfe, ich mein, warum sollen die das im Mittelalter auf einmal verlernt haben?
Die meisten Leute, denen ist eigentlich klar, dass Römer immer in Formation gekämpft haben, also das war nichts Neues damals auch schon, ja,
und warum sollen die das von den Römern zum Mittelalter verlernt haben, das ergibt ja überhaupt keinen Sinn, das war, die haben alle in Formation gekämpft,
oder sie haben 360 Quickscope gemacht, kann auch sein, die ganzen Schlachten, das war, da wurde in Formation gekämpft, deswegen war es ja auch so wichtig,
wie sich wer wo positioniert hat, du konntest allein schon mal durch bessere Positionierung entscheiden,
deswegen war es ja auch quasi so wichtig, dass du verschiedene Ranks, dass du mehrere Reihen hattest und sowas,
was meint ihr, was passiert, wenn die Gegner einmal irgendwie durch sind, dann ist ja Chaos, da hast du keine ordentliche Formation mehr,
also es wurde im Mittelalter auch, zum größten Teilen, wenn Schlachten ausgetragen wurden, wurden die in Formation ausgeführt, selbstverständlich,
deswegen gibt es ja diese Sache, die in einem, ich frag mich nicht, in irgendeinem mittelalterlichen so Fecht Lehrbuch oder so steht,
dass nicht der Gegner vor dir der gefährlichste ist, sondern neben dran, den du nicht siehst, oder auf den du nicht achtest,
und es ist so, wenn die da stehen, in der Regel mit Schwert und Speer, das war übrigens nix Zweihänder und nix irgendwie großartiges Schwert,
Schwert war Secondary, Schild und Speer war angesagt, auch übrigens bei Wikigern, wo immer so erzählt wird mit Axt und in your face,
das war zum größten Teil Speer und Schild, Speer und Schild war so 0815, war für irgendwie 2000 Jahre, wenn man es so will, und da wurden in Formation gekämpft,
weil man muss sich mal überlegen, wann kommt der Linux-Kram, wenn ich mit meinem Mittelalter rein fertig bin, also in 5 Minuten oder so,
man muss sich mal überlegen, man kann ja auch mit Schild und Speer, man kann ja auch nur in Formation kämpfen,
wie soll das funktionieren, soll da jeder Wild mit seinem Speer rumstochern und rumfuchteln und irgendwie noch sein Nachbar das Auge ausstechen oder so,
also wenn man sich ein bisschen damit beschäftigt, ich finde das ein sehr interessantes Thema, dann wird man feststellen, dass die Darstellung der meisten mittelalterlicher Sachen
in Filmen und auch in Spielen kompletter Bullshit ist.
Geht es dir, also wie es dir im Kaboom geht, gerade weiß ich, aber mir geht es wieder besser, man haltet so nicht mehr.
Wikinger hatten auch keine Hörner, richtig, Wikinger an sich waren eh nur die, also es wird ja ein Film, wir legen jetzt mal eine VM an und machen das Linux-Zeug,
geht es dir excellent, ah, noch nicht, noch nicht excellent, ah yes, excellent, Wikinger waren ja auch nur die, die raiden gegangen sind.
Also es war nicht jeder Skandinavier Wikinger, Wikinger waren nur die, die auf Raids gegangen sind, die World First Boss Clear gemacht haben.
Irgendwo in England zum größten Teil.
Okay, jetzt legen wir uns mal das Linux-Zeug an, das waren eigentlich Wikinger, der Rest waren halt so stinknormale Skandinavier,
die zum größten Teil als Bauern gelebt haben, so wie hier auch.
Also war nicht so, dass da jeder Skandinavier zu der damaligen Zeit mit Rüstung und Axt rum gerannt ist und alles gebashed hat oder so.
Zumal Rüstung war eh so eine Sache, ne, ne, Installer-Disc brauchen wir nicht.
Rüstung in der eigentlichen Form, wie sie da teilweise zeigen mit Plattenrüstung und sowas, das gab es für eine ganz, ganz lange Zeit gar nicht.
Den größten Teil war, dass die Kettenhemden anhaben, Kettenhemden oder dicke Jacken im Endeffekt.
So, wir brauchen eine Linie um 64 Bit, so, CPUs machen wir mal 2, 2, 4, 4, wir haben 6 Stück, das reicht.
Nächstes Assassin's Creed ist ja vielleicht mit Wikigern, da bin ich mal gespannt drauf, ja.
Da bin ich mal gespannt drauf, wie sie das, wenn sie das machen, wie sie das machen.
Ob das irgendwie was mit der Realität zu tun hat, weil man muss sagen, Assassin's Creed, die sind eigentlich
ziemlich gut drin, historische Ereignisse einzufangen.
Der Galileo guck ich nicht.
Aber es gibt jede Menge gute Channels auf YouTube, die sich mit solchen Themen beschäftigen.
Create New Disc, wir sind, wir machen jetzt mal YOLO, YOLO Style, also wir haben leider nur noch, oh fuck, 60,4G, fuck.
Ich mach mal 10G, ich, ansonsten müssen wir erstmal aufräumen, wir gucken mal, ob es drauf passt.
Mal gucken, ob das ausreicht, 10 Gigabyte.
Und wir machen mal den Drucker weg, weil den braucht kein Mensch.
Wir machen den Drucker weg und wir machen die 3D-Beschleunigung an, genau.
Vor allem Escapes, nein, haben wir noch nicht angeguckt, wir wollen das ja im Stream angucken.
Wird eine SSD nicht langsamer, wenn sie ganz voll ist?
Ich will jetzt nicht pauschal sagen, nee, weil es bestimmt Grenzfälle gibt, wo das so sein könnte.
Kenne ich mich nicht mit gut genug aus, aber ich wüsste nicht, warum die großartig langsamer werden soll.
Vielleicht die Dinger, die pro Zelle irgendwie Magic machen, dass sie mehr speichern können oder so, weiß ich nicht.
Aber eigentlich fällt mir da nicht so viel ein.
Also wo SSDs auf jeden Fall langsamer werden könnten, ist beim Schreiben, wenn sie sehr voll sind und auch schon der ganze Reserve-Kram voll ist.
Dann könnte ich mir das vorstellen, aber ansonsten wüsste ich nicht, warum.
Ist jemand von euch eine glorreiche Idee, warum SSDs langsamer werden sollen?
Ey, du hast ja bei SSD Reserve, du hast ja bei jeder SSD einiges an ungenutzten Speicherplatz drin.
Okay, mal gucken, ob 10 GB Speicherplatz reichen.
Wow!
Alter, die Chinesen!
Die Chinesen sind am Start.
Was hat er jetzt eigentlich für Boot-Optionen ausgewählt?
Was hat er denn jetzt für Boot-Optionen ausgewählt?
Ah, jetzt, Leute, Leute, Leute, ich starte, ich starte noch mal kurz neu.
Ich glaube, das ist jetzt nicht vm.
Hallo? Geht das nicht? Muss man jetzt außen wieder einschalten, oder?
Na gut, Select System Language, mal mal, Englisch.
Natürlich haben wir das User Agreement gelesen.
Ah, jetzt, wir lesen, wir lesen immer User Agreements.
Gibt es überhaupt jemand, der kein User Agreements liest?
So, Englisch.
Next.
Okay, Leute.
Boah, Schlug auf.
Exit, wir müssen aufräumen.
Okay.
Was kann man aufräumen? Ich muss Platz machen.
Platz, okay, Downloads.
Wie können die ganzen ISOs, guck mal hier.
ISOs können wir löschen.
Windows 10 ISO brauchen wir nicht mehr.
Sorin ISO brauchen wir nicht mehr.
Popo Esmanjaro Architekt brauchen wir, brauchen wir alles weg.
Alles weg.
Weg.
Alles, alles weg.
So.
Mal löschen und gucken, wie viel Platz wir dann haben.
Recycle, Recycle, da ist er.
Ha.
Easy.
Excellent.
So muss das sein.
Gut.
Dann können wir weiter machen.
Vielleicht kommt der Porn League.
Ja, das kann nicht passieren, weil ich für Streamen...
What the hell?
Alter, was ist mit dir, was ist mit den Chinesen los?
Weil ich für Streamen abgeschotteten User Account habe.
Kann nix leaken.
Ich kann nicht aussehen, Fotos oder sonst was leaken.
Oder irgendwas hier von mir.
Geht nicht.
Big Brain.
Ähm.
Gut.
Kann man da jetzt eigentlich die Platte expand disk?
25.
Hard.
Nice.
Okay.
Pog.
Void Danny.
Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön.
Big Prime.
Big Brain.
Huge.
Sub.
Dankeschön.
Okay.
Warum piepsten die immer?
Das erschreckt mich.
Void Danny, fünf Monate.
Nicht Schlag am Start.
Du bist ja auch ein Gründer, sehe ich ja gerade hier.
Founders Edition.
Okay, mal gucken, ob wir jetzt installieren dürfen.
Next.
Username.
Okay.
Cute.
Chat.
Azzazza.
Cute.
Chat.
Passwort.
Was?
Ist das jetzt euer Ernst?
Cute.
Chat.
Okay.
Ah, ja, ja.
Passwort.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs.
Da fehlt die Hälfte vom Text.
Ja.
Ach, hier, guck mal, hier oben kann man ja umstellen.
Hier oben kann man ja umstellen.
Auf German.
German.
No.
Da.
No dead keys.
Was?
What?
Was ist das jetzt?
Was ist no dead keys?
Dass zum Beispiel das da nach dem ersten Mal drücken kommt und sowas.
Weil der Knopf ist quasi nach dem ersten Mal drücken dead.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das die richtige Erklärung dafür ist.
Was möchtest du mir sagen?
Ich hab doch nur die Tastaturlayout geändert.
Okay, continue.
Weg.
Ah, ich hätte nicht da oben auf abbrechen dürfen klicken.
Wo kann ich das in Windows einstellen?
Du fragst mich hier wirklich, wo Windows-Settings sind.
Weil ich bin ja auch so der Wahnsinns-Windows-Experte, ne?
Haben wir nicht letztens eine halbe Stunde gesucht, um irgendwie ein Custom-, äh, zusätzlich
Tastaturlayout zu finden in Windows?
Okay, wir sind in Berlin, richtig?
Free Space?
Oh, guck mal.
Es ist transformiert, meine Hard-Disc in Deepin Linux.
Deepin Linux ist schon ein bisschen, äh, ne?
Der Name ist schon...
Da könnte man an die falschen Sachen denken, vielleicht.
Simple, Full-Disc.
Bam, Deepin.
Und die ganze Disc wird hier...
Encrypt?
Oh, das muss ich ausprobieren, ob das geht.
China-Encryption.
An was mich das erinnert, Michael?
Das erinnert mich an Monka Toss.
Das können wir hier jetzt so nicht besprechen im Stream.
So, please confirm...
Okay, das ist nicht für kleine Bildschirme ausgelegt, auf jeden Fall.
Wir erstellen eine MS-DOS-New-Portition-Table.
Max Reuter, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
900 IQ-Sub.
Mach einfach mal Linux.
Äh, nicht Linux, äh, China-Linux, mach mal.
Installing, okay, gucken wir da Sachen zu.
Während das installiert, möchte ich noch mal zurückkommen hier auf diesen, äh,.NET.
Diesen.NET-Controller.
Und zwar, was ich dazu sagen wollte, ist, deswegen ich hab mal einen bestellt.
Er ist, er ist für einen, für einen, für einen Micro-Controller ist es viel zu teuer.
Wenn man das Ding kauft, ähm, kauft, kauft, kostet 50 Dollar.
50 Dollar für so einen Micro-Controller ist eigentlich viel zu viel.
Es sei denn, er macht damit irgendwie was Großartiges vor.
Äh, wenn man sich überlegt, ein ESP-8266 kostet 3 Dollar.
DerFixer615 sagt, ich habe keinen Twitch Prime.
Bei der Gelegenheit sollte ich euch vielleicht noch mal darauf hinweisen,
dass wenn ihr Amazon Prime habt, dass es relativ einfach ist,
einen Amazon-Account mit seinem Twitch-Account zu verbinden.
Wenn man das gemacht hat, hat man nämlich automatisch Twitch Prime
und kann einen Streamer seiner Wahl mit einem kostenlosen T1-Sub unterstützen.
Und der Streamer hat alle Vorteile von und ihr auch.
Und es kostet euch nichts.
Also eigentlich die beste Variante, um Leute auf Twitch zu unterstützen, die man gerne kuckt.
So sieht's aus.
Achso, und was der FloFastFlo96 sagt, stimmt natürlich auch.
Ich find's gut, dass so viele Leute in letzter Zeit zugucken.
Ähm, ich hab's ja, ich hab, ich brauch die Kohle ja nicht.
Ich bin, ich freu mich über jeden, der subscribt.
Aber ich freu mich genauso, wenn Leute einfach nur da sind, zugucken und im Chat aktiv sind.
Ist Chromium viel besser als Chrome?
Nö, im Prinzip genau das Gleiche.
Nur ein paar weniger Google-Sachen.
Nur ein paar weniger Google-Sachen dabei.
Alles das Gleiche.
Also, ähm, was ich zu diesem Controller noch sagen wollte, während das installiert.
Okay, da brauchen wir noch ein bisschen. Guck dir an, da brauchen wir noch ein bisschen.
Die bewerben halt hier sehr vollmundig alle möglichen Sachen.
Zum Beispiel das Battery Life.
It's ultra low energy.
Soll ich nur an, also im Prinzip wollen sie uns sagen, ähm...
Oh, ich hab mich verlesen.
Ah, nee, doch.
Years, Jahre, Jahre kann dieser Controller laufen an einer Batterie.
Da hab ich meine großen Zweifel dran.
Dass das, ja, was, ich mein, von welcher, von welcher, ähm, Batterie reden wir hier?
Reden wir hier von so einem ganz normalen Akku, so mit, sagen wir mal, 1000, 1200 bis 2000 mAh?
Oder reden wir jetzt hier von einem Tesla Akku?
Max brauchen ein Statement, was?
Kommen 20, 20. Videos auf YouTube? Ja, kommen, auf jeden Fall.
Gibt es.
Gibt's auf jeden Fall.
So, und wenn wir mal von einer normalen, wenn wir mal von einer normalen Batterie ausgehen, die man für so ein Projekt nimmt,
dann ist das so ein kleiner, so ein Akku ist das.
Und das sind schon die bisschen größeren, ja?
So mit 1200 mAh, 3,2 Volt, die haben dann geladen irgendwie 4,2.
Und ich hab meine Zweifel, dass das Jahre hält.
Wir reden ja auch nicht von dauerhaft, dauerhaft laufend, ist mir schon klar.
Aber selbst im Deep Sleep brauchen die Dinger ein bisschen was.
Und Jahre ist, ist schon sehr, äh, wie sagt man so, sehr optimistisch geschätzt, ja?
Wir haben es ja mal ausgerechnet im Stream.
Experience now.
Okay, dann, dann experiencen wir das jetzt mal now.
Und wir haben es ja im Stream mal ausgerechnet, wenn du so ein, wenn du ein sehr, sehr stromsparendes ESP32 Board nimmst,
so ein Fire Beetle 32 zum Beispiel, ähm, und den nur fünfmal am Tag aufwachen lässt,
dann hält die Batterie zwei Jahre, optimistisch gesehen.
Und das ist fast nichts, ja?
Zwei mal, fünfmal am Tag aufwachen lassen und Rest Deep Sleep.
Und, ähm, auf dem Ding ist deutlich mehr, auf dem Ding hier.
Und das ist schon sehr optimistisch, würde ich mal sagen.
Ich mein, der Calculator sagt fünf Jahre, aber niemals sind das fünf Jahre, ja?
Zwei Jahre, ich denke, zwei Jahre sind realistisch bis optimistisch.
Und auf diesem Ding hier ist noch eine ganze Ecke mehr drauf.
Ähm, inklusive übrigens auch einem ESP32 für Wi-Fi, für WLAN.
Das ist nochmal, ist nochmal mit, mit dabei.
Ähm, die müssten schon sehr, sehr cleffere Deep Sleep, äh, Powerspar-Geschichte haben,
dass das mehrere Jahre auf normalen Akku läuft.
Was viel cooler wäre, ist, wenn das annehmbar lange auf einer noch kleineren,
auf einer noch kleineren Akku laufen würde, weil so die 1200 mAh Akkus,
die sind halt auch ein bisschen groß für so richtig kleine Anwendungen.
Okay Leute, Aja ja, Deep in Linux ist am Start.
Wir müssen übrigens als erstes wieder VMA-Tools installieren,
dass wir eine ordentliche Auflösung haben.
Also, Aja ja, wir haben schon mal ein schönes, ähm, Profil-Pick.
Nämlich Luftballons.
Warum auch immer Luftballons? Aber Luftballons ist ja schon mal nice.
Boah.
Friendly Reminder.
Oh, hoho. Alter, ich bin begeistert.
Die erste Distribution, die das sinnvoll macht.
Hatten wir noch nie? Hatten wir noch nie?
Dass das Ding erkennt, dass man in der VMA läuft,
dann... Okay, also it has detected that you are using a virtual machine,
which will affect the system.
Okay, also soll ich Normal Mode machen oder Effect Mode?
Also Leute, was, was wollen wir machen? Den Effect Mode oder den Normal Mode?
Ich meine, der Effect Mode ist langsamer, wir können aber beides ausbringen.
Wir machen erstmal den Effect Mode, ne? Effect.
Ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen, wenn ich jetzt ausschalte,
weil der ja schon erkannt hat, dass ich in der VMA bin,
weil der ja schon erkannt hat, dass ich in der VMA bin, wenn ich das...
Was zum... Ah ja, geht jetzt ab.
Das ist ein Einführungsvideo.
Das ist ein Einführungsvideo, Leute.
Das finde ich gut.
Ich meine, was auch immer uns das jetzt sagen soll, kein Schimmer, aber next.
Please, das finde ich richtig gut.
Ich meine, jetzt mal wirklich, jetzt mal ernsthaft, ne?
Diese Alexa-Sache am Anfang ist nervig und überflüssig, aber mal...
Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass jeder schon mal vor dem Linux gesessen hat, aber...
Einführungsvideo ist doch ne coole Sache.
Please select desktop mode. Fashion mode.
Efficient mode.
Okay, Mac OS Mode, Windows Mode.
Efficient.
Mac. Ja. Ja, ja.
Chat. Was sagt ihr?
Cute Chat.
Fashion. Fashion. Effect. Efficient. Mac.
Oh. Efficient. Fashion.
Scheiße.
Das ist 50-50 jetzt.
Also das Ding macht gerne Geräusche, habe ich jetzt schon festgestellt.
Okay, dann schalten wir erstmal...
Wir bleiben erst... Wir gehen jetzt erstmal den Mac OS fake und danach stellen wir uns auf Efficient Mode.
Und gucken uns das Ganze an.
Okay. Fashion Mode.
Window Effects.
Wie sieht denn so ein Window Effect überhaupt... Oh.
Oh. Ah, nee.
Ah, Transparenz und solche Geschichten. Okay, verstehe.
Wir lassen. Ach, man sieht es ja auch hier unten. Guck mal, man sieht es ja auch hier unten.
Wir machen mal volle Pulle. Ich meine, das ist eine VM, das wird nicht so wahnsinnig schnell sein, aber...
Solange es halbwegs geht...
Brauchen wir Sounds, Deepin Entwickler. Ja. So sieht es aus, ja.
Ey, ich bin echt froh, dass diese YouTube-Comments vorbei sind.
Niemand. Niemand. Wirklich niemand. Absolut niemand.
Max. Oder so. Kennt ihr... Die waren so richtig... Das waren so richtig low-effort-Memes immer.
So richtig low-quality-Memes waren das immer.
So richtig dumm.
Die sind noch nicht ganz vorbei. Also...
Nachzügler. So die...
No-Brain-Leute, die sind da immer noch bei.
Boomer. Genau. Alles Boomer. Im Zweifelsfall.
Ich muss ja mal was loswerden. So dieser ganzen...
Boomer, Zoomer, sonst was Geschichte. Ich weiß, wir wollen jetzt eigentlich Linux angucken, aber das muss ich jetzt mal sagen...
Ich hätte nie gedacht...
Ähm...
Dass die Generation nach mir...
Unfähiger ist...
Mit Technik teilweise umzugehen, wie die Generation vor mir.
Also...
Ich muss sagen, ich bin ja so ein Zwischen-Spieler, ich bin ja Hybrid-Boomer.
Ich bin nicht wirklich Boomer, von der Zeit her.
Und ich bin auch nicht wirklich Zoomer, von der Zeit her.
1984 geboren, das heißt, ich bin 35, ich bin so...
Bezoomer. Keine Ahnung, sowas dazwischen.
Das Beste aus beiden Welten sozusagen.
Und...
Ich hab das bei manchen Azubis bei uns gesehen.
Und das sind fachinformatige Azubis.
Zoomer. Genau, Zoomer.
Ähm...
Wie wenig Plan man von Technik haben kann.
Ich hätte es nicht für möglich gehalten. Ganz ehrlich, ich hätte es nicht für möglich gehalten.
Dass... Quasi, dass jemand, der in der Generation nach mir geboren ist...
Probleme hat, oder besser gesagt, dass die Generation nach mir...
Nicht flächendeckend, komplett in der Lage ist...
Einen Internetanschluss zu bestellen und eine Fritz-Box einzurichten.
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht. Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, okay...
Die Generation nach mir, denen ist das quasi mehr oder weniger schon in die Wiege gelegt.
Das kann dann jeder.
Aber es ist viel schlimmer.
Es ist viel schlimmer.
Sie können es zum größten Teil genauso wenig...
Wie die Generation... ähm... vor mir.
Nur mit dem Unterschied. Mit dem Unterschied.
Und das ist der große Unterschied.
Dass die Generation vor mir noch richtig oldschool ist...
Und das Handbuch liest...
Wohingegen die Zoomer-Generation entweder direkt einen Sucht, das für sie macht...
Weil irgendwie low effort übelst in ist...
Oder aber versucht zu googeln und ich weiß was auf ihrem Smartphone.
Also ich bin echt immer wieder erschrocken, dass sogar...
Fachinformatiker anfangen am Anfang.
Also angehende Fachinformatiker Azubis...
Nicht wissen, was sie in der Fritz-Box anklicken müssen.
Das ist immer so ein kleiner Test, den ich gerne mache.
Wir haben ja eigentlich keine Fritz-Box, aber wir haben doch eine Fritz-Box.
Die ist... ähm... die haben wir auf der Arbeit für... für Dinger.
Normalerweise geht das ja übers Hausnetz, aber wir haben quasi eine eigene Fritz-Box.
Und eine super tolle Aufgabe für neue Azubis ist... ähm...
Ich habe das Passwort vergessen.
Es soll mal die Fritz-Box resetten und neu einrichten.
Das mache ich mit dem nächsten auch wieder.
Ich glaube in 2 oder 3 Wochen, am 20. kommt glaube ich wieder einer.
Das mache ich mit dem auch wieder.
Und es ist erstaunlich, wie viele angehende Fachinformatiker...
es nicht hinkriegen eine Fritz-Box zu resetten.
Das ist im Prinzip ganz easy.
Wenn ich es nicht weiß, kann ich sogar im Internet nachgucken.
Man findet das auch.
Und es gibt so ein paar... vielleicht guckt ja derjenige zufälligerweise zu...
und da kann er mich begeistern.
Es gibt ja mehrere Sachen, wie man das machen kann, ja.
Ähm... die billigste... also sag mal so...
die absolut Low-Brain-Variante, die ich auch nicht machen werde...
ist mir eine neue zu kaufen.
Die nächste Variante ist... ähm...
das Ding zu resetten.
Die nächste Variante ist, dass... ähm...
die Dinger haben so ein Rescue-Interface.
Wenn man sich daran anschließt und spezielle IP eingibt...
kommt man zumindest wieder auf das Web-Interface drauf.
Und solche Dinger.
Aber mir würde es schon reichen, wenn die die Anleitung finden...
es nach der Anleitung resetten...
und in WLAN-Passwort vergeben, was ich Ihnen vorher sage.
Aber es ist erstaunlich, wie viele Leute, quasi Generationen nach mir...
das auch nicht hinbekommen.
Das hätte ich nie für möglich gehalten früher.
Ich habe mittlerweile echt den Eindruck...
dass... wo man immer so sagt...
Digital Native und so...
das Einzige, was Native ist...
ist die Bedienung von, sagen wir mal, Snapchat.
Liegt vielleicht auch daran, dass Informatik-Lehrer aus...
Natürlich, Informatik-Lehrer sind ja noch eine Generation vor mir.
So, Enable Windows Effects.
Please select I can see...
Guck mal, gibt es ja auch mehrere Sachen.
Papyrus...
Deep in...
Deep in Dark.
Oh, da ist ja wahnsinnig ein Unterschied dazwischen.
Der Papierkorb ist schwarz.
Huge.
Hat es sonst eigentlich einen großen Unterschied?
Papyrus hatte ich mal eine Weile bei mir auf Majaro als...
als Icon-Theme.
Der Router, 23 Poggers.
Dankeschön für... Ah nee, sind da keine Bits.
Okay.
Dann erwähne ich das jetzt nicht.
Bits all didn't happen.
Poggers, sagt er. Der Router.
Debated.
Ah, du hast aber viele...
nicht Bits, sondern Channel-Points.
Äh...
Dennis glaube ich dir sofort.
Wir nehmen... wir nehmen Deep in Dark einfach weil Dark Seen beste ist, ja?
Das mit der Sonnenbrille passt nicht so ganz zum E-Mode, oder?
Können wir mal gucken, ob die Stream vorschaut, die Sun-Clairs, oder?
Ja.
Können wir mal gucken, ob die Stream vorschaut, die Sun-Clairs das richtig anzeigt?
Der Chat im Stream.
Zeigt der Wub-Alt mit der Sonnenbrille an?
Meine Vorschau-Spektrum geht nicht.
Ja. Oh, nice.
Richtig gut das Zeug.
Okay, Dark Seen.
Control-Center, gucken wir mal.
Okay, das erinnert mich schon wieder ekligerweise an Windows 10.
Die Sonnenbrille ist kaputt.
Das liegt aber an Twitch.
Okay, das erinnert mich erstaunlich an Windows 10, dieses Ding hier neben dran.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass sie den Platz sinnvoll verwenden im Vergleich zu Windows 10.
Ich meine, guckt euch dieses dämliche Menü bei Windows 10 an.
Guckt da, ernste Frage, wirklich, wirklich hier.
Real Talk mal, Leute, ja?
Ernst gemeinte Frage.
Öffnet dieses Ding von euch irgendjemand.
Benutzt das, dieses Menü.
Benutzt das wirklich irgendjemand?
Ihr jebaitet mich jetzt, Leute.
Ihr verarscht mich.
Also alle, die jetzt Ja geschrieben haben, verarschen mich.
Ich glaube euch das nicht.
Echt?
Youpad, okay.
Habe ich nichts gesagt.
Es gibt tatsächlich Leute, die das Ganze verwenden.
Wahrscheinlich ist das einfach zu massiv für mein Gehirn.
Das passt doch nicht rein, das Menü.
Okay, ja, vielleicht zum Bluetooth an- und ausschalten oder sowas.
Aber zu 90% hat man das Menü auf und das ist eigentlich relativ sinnvoll.
Sinnlos.
Zumal, wenn man hier auf All Settings klickt, nicht im Seitenmenü aufgeht, sondern in ein eigenes Fenster.
Also es ist irgendwie ziemlich unsinnig.
Der einzige Anlass, wann ich dieses Menü aufmache, ist, wenn Windows wieder mal die Durchsage macht,
dass der Windows Defender nichts gefunden hat.
Das ist ja auch geil.
Der Windows Defender macht einmal im Monat eine Meldung, ich habe nichts gefunden.
Ich habe jetzt zwei Wochen gescannt und habe nichts gefunden.
Ich habe zwei Wochen gescannt und ich habe nichts gefunden.
Ich habe übrigens zwei Wochen gescannt und nichts gefunden.
Das macht der Windows Defender immer.
Das muss er mir mitteilen.
Ich meine, es wäre ja schon cool, wenn der Windows Defender mir mitteilen würde, wenn er was gefunden hat.
Ich muss nicht wissen, wenn er nichts gefunden hat.
Das ist ja gerade der Witz von einem Viren-Scanner.
Okay, Updates. Updates detected.
Und ich muss sagen, das Gefällt- also das Bedienkonzept bis jetzt gefällt mir von allen,
von allen Linux Sachen, die wir bisher ausprobiert haben.
Also von diesen normalen Desktop Linux Sachen.
Am besten gefällt mir natürlich immer noch mein Customized Manjaro Linux.
Aber das gefällt mir bis jetzt am besten.
Das macht, das macht wirklich schlüssig den Gesamteindruck.
Mal gucken, ob sich das so fortsetzt.
Okay, Download und In- ah, okay, geht doch.
Choose My Name sagt,
mein IT-Lehrer im Gymnasium war unter anderem für Netzwerkzeuge zuständig.
Er hat uns ein Jahr lang quasi nicht unterrichtet
und hat uns allein lernen lassen, weil er Fritzboxen einrichten muss.
Aha, habt ihr übrigens Fritzboxen einrichten gelernt mit ihm auch.
Später erfuhren wir dann von einem anderen Netzwerk-Admin,
das der Schule keine einzige Fritzbox- Fritzbox besitzt.
Okay, das heißt im Endeffekt, der hat sich gedrückt.
Um so auszudrücken.
Ihr habt einfach keinen Bock auf euch gehabt.
Das kann ich ja nachvollziehen.
Das wäre ehrlich von dem Lehrer irgendwie.
Das kann ich nachvollziehen.
Ich hätte auch keinen Bock auf eine Klasse voller Schüler.
Da sage ich euch ganz ehrlich, ja.
Äh, oh, ich sehe es ja jetzt erst.
Vor acht Minuten.
Hier, Rusty hat subscribt, Woop S und der...
Das ist schwierig auszusprechen.
Schrar, sage ich jetzt einfach mal.
Der Schrar hat auch subscribt.
Danke schön an euch beide für den Bigprane-Sub.
Und ähm, der Schrar hat noch geschrieben,
haben letztens in der Schule USB-Sticks benutzt.
Mehr als die Hälfte konnte damit nicht umgehen.
Das kann ich mir wiederum jetzt auch.
Das ist schon fast zu übertrieben.
Was heißt, konnten nicht damit umgehen?
Ich meine, was muss man bei einem USB-Stick machen?
In Anschluss stecken.
Also, das kriegt doch jeder gemacht.
New System Edition 4 Update Selected.
Ok, install Updates.
Weiter, mach, mach hinne.
Deep in.
Deep in Patches.
WPS Office.
EPS?
Ist das Kingsoft?
King, King, Kingdings Office?
Nein, das Problem gibt es ja demnächst mit USB-C nicht mehr.
Da kannst du es reinstecken, wie du willst.
Tipp für einen Router, der standardzeugskant und solide ist.
Ich würde dir empfehlen, äh, Moment.
Ich muss jetzt ein bisschen mehr dazu sagen.
Willst du wirklich einen Router und WLAN?
Oder willst du so ein Multifunktionsgerät wie die Fritzbox?
Also sprich, was auch ein DSL-Modem hat,
was die Einwahl ins Internet machen kann,
was, äh, Decktelefone anschließend benutzen kann,
was, äh, VoIP kann.
Willst du ein Multifunktionsgerät wie die Fritzbox?
Oder bist du wirklich auf der Suche nach einem Router und WLAN?
Update, Restart, wie du das ja wie unter Windows.
Warum kann WIN?
Reboot.
Hahaha, das ist schon der Klassiker hier.
Äh, Flow 96.
Das ist ja schon der Klassiker hier.
Bill Gates und der Windows 98 Blue Screen.
Wer es nicht kennt, das ist ja schon der Klassiker mittlerweile.
Das ist, das ist aber zu geil.
Huge quali by the way.
Das ist Windows 98 Vorstellung.
Windows 98 Präsentation ist das.
Hahaha, Blue Screen.
Vor allem, wie sie es weggeschaltet haben.
Du musst mal gucken, wie sie es wegschalten.
Das ist schon der Klassiker mittlerweile.
Hahaha.
Moving right along.
That must be, that must be why we're not shipping Windows 98 yet.
Absolutely, absolutely.
Aber richtig gut, wie er darauf reagiert hat, ne?
So nach dem Motto, wenn wir es rausbringen, dann ist dieser Bug ja weg.
Er hat richtig gut drauf reagiert.
Äh, ah jetzt, okay.
Okay, diese komische Funktion ist von Windows.
Oh, oh, oh.
Okay, das spackt rum, wenn man an den Bildschirmrand geht, äh.
Guck mal, was wir haben.
Ui, ui.
Ähm.
Okay, also ich habe diese komische Setting des Zeugs.
Was kann man da so alles machen?
Transpiration.
VPN, DSL.
What the fuck, Alter, was?
Erstmal China, erstmal China VPN anmachen.
Transparency.
Aha.
Also ich muss euch sagen, ich finde die Idee von, von der, ähm.
Von diesem, diese, diesem.
Benutzerinterface, wie sie es gemacht haben.
Eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht.
Theme.
Deep in Dark, guck mal, man kann es auch komplett dunkel machen.
Machen wir mal einen File Manager auf.
Der ist jetzt dunkel.
Okay.
Ah, jaja.
Muss man das irgendwie speichern oder so?
Und das, das muss man bestimmt irgendwie speichern, oder?
Der File Manager hat nochmal eine Extra-Einstellung?
Nee, oder?
Doch.
WTF.
Okay.
What?
Chrome ist dunkel, aber der File Manager
nicht.
Deep in ist debian, stable.
Also ist, ist von der Software her relativ alt.
Also stimmt, wir müssen mal wieder unsere
Linux Bewertungskriterien aufmachen.
Dass wir wissen, was wir gucken müssen.
Ja.
Äh, diese drei Balcony.
ernsthaft jetzt
ok das ist richtig pepega
also das ist wirklich
das ist extra
ja warum
also für mich wirkt das
wirkt das wie der übelste pepega move
man schaltet dark theme an aber den
feinmanager muss dann mal auf dark theme schalten
warum
open vmware tools, nee brauche ich
nicht
haben sie selbst installiert
und das rechne ich dem
china linux wirklich hoch an
also das ist die erste distribution
die ich ausprobiert habe
die sagt, die erkennt
jawoll ich laufe in einer vm und installiere
vm tools
also das ist wirklich
gut, ich meine es ist nichts
großartiges, das ist ein script
zwei zeilen
aber das macht keiner
das finde ich ziemlich
gut
big brain linux
ok, window aus tast
funktioniert auch, kann man hier nach
so was wie themes suchen
terminal, ok da bin ich mal
gespannt wie das terminal aussieht
was ist computer
terminal
iii
oh was ist das
wie soll man so was
wie soll man da drin arbeiten
ist ja mr robot
staffel 5 hier
ok
was ist denn das für ein terminal
ist das was selbst programmiert ist von denen
das scheint mal selbst programmiert zu sein
von denen
der findet theme wahrscheinlich weil man hier auch ein theme einstellen kann
im terminal
ok als erstes
müssen wir die transparenz ausschalten
ich bin ja persönlich
nur meine persönliche meinung
alle die terminal
mit transparenz verwenden
die werden über kurz oder lang
probleme mit den augen bekommen
knerber ich hab doch nichts gespoilert
alter
ich hab gesagt dass siri eine oma
hat
aber es ist schön dass du mich dafür zappst
subscriber
das reicht mir verdammt
knerber
ich kann dich auch nochmal spoilern
ich hab auch ne oma oder ich hatte auch ne oma
das ist auch huge spoiler
und ich vermute mal dass sogar
der knerber eine oma hatte
oder hat
ich hoffe natürlich noch hat
aber sogar du hattest ne oma
ich weiß es kommt vielleicht überraschend jetzt
aber ich bin mir relativ sicher
öffne mal das chinesische
file
wo ist dein chinesisch
oh guck mal da
wie mach ich denn das auf
moment
cd
was ist da drinnen
docks
ne powerpoint presentation
ist da drinnen
ah yes alles klar
oh
kann man das dobbie auch
einen ausspionieren
wir könnten
einen mojah shark anmachen aber
äh warum
confirm
yes
oh
Das ist ja eine tolle präsentation
Update now moment wir haben doch gerade geupdatet
Okay pdf update now
Update
What the fuck
Wir haben doch geupdatet
Update
Update und findet er update nicht
Update er findet kein update okay das schon mal fail
Konnte man hier updaten
Update hier
Choose my name das wird wahrscheinlich so sein aber das ist dann schon schlechte schlechte benutzer experience
Dann müssten sie das hier irgendwie unterdrücken
Ignore it, komm wir machen ein ignore wie ignoren wir das jetzt
Okay, das ist das china word das ist das china word skin center aber guck mal das ist das ist auch nur teilweise dark theme
Skin center
Die folgt da die folgen ja das ist super das ist der fensterrahmen
Desktop documents. Ja ja ja ja desktop
Wow, warum geht mein vm-ding hier oben auf aber exklusiv okay wir erstellen jetzt mal
Das sieht das sieht ein bisschen
Das sieht aus wie so ein hybrid so ein hybrid aus aus microsoft office und open office
Sieht das aus oder findet ihr nicht auch
Das ist so eine mischung also die
Die icons und die menü sind so das sieht von den farben und wie billig die gemacht sind sind die aus wie open office
Aber der rest ist so ein bisschen ribbon style von microsoft
Wobei ich sagen muss ich finde wahrscheinlich alles besser
Als
Open office beziehungsweise die pro office ihr wisst ich verwende überhaupt keine office pro kramme aber
Lieb pro office ist wirklich eine zumutung
Das sage ich als linux und open source fern aber lieb pro office ist wirklich
Anstrengend
Aber macht so wie ich schreibt eure sachen wo es geht in markt da und exportiert als pdf
Und ihr müsst euch nicht mehr rum ärgern mit mit office pro kramme ok omega lull
Kalibri ist kalibri nicht auch die standardschrift von wort
Warum sollte man sich ein anderes betriebssystem als windows holen kommt drauf an was du machen willst also wenn du wenn du mit windows zufrieden bist
Spielen willst vielleicht pro kamas die nur unter windows gehen gibt es gibt es wenig wenig gründe
Wenn du zum beispiel gerne netzwerkgeschichten machst programmierst dich vielleicht auch ein bisschen für die serverwelt interessiert oder sich auch für
Neue cloud sachen und technik interessiert da kommt es an linux nicht vorbei
Was nimmt man dann bei wissenschaftlichen arbeiten oder so latech oder so
Ok omega lull
So und da können wir jetzt was draus machen kann man ein wort art eigentlich bräuchte review
Das ist ok das ist das ist ziemlicher
Ziemlicher ripoff vom vom
Ribbon von der microsoft ribbon war
Aber es kann schon mal zu pdf exportieren und das
Das ist ein bisschen komisch
Also die farbgestaltung hier ist bisschen unpassend aber da wollen wir nicht so pöpselig
er sein als der pabst ich will ein wort art machen wps art
Trappi sweet list ich wollte schon immer eine trappi sweet list machen ah ich esse trappi sweet list
exzellent trappi sweet
Ich finde nicht auch dass es die beste trappi sweet liste überhaupt ist beste trappi sweet liste iu west
Oh man kann sie sogar einzeln löschen was war das hier um guck mal da man kann ja noch magic sachen einstellen
Trappi sweet im leben noch nicht gehört ist auch nichts was ich verwenden will
Da oben in der mitte noch ein bisschen
Viertel da oben in der mitte gibt es sogar wort an wo wo wo
wort art
Ok man klaut halt mal ganz ungeniert ja es juckt nicht jolo
Aber ich muss euch sagen es sieht besser aus als wort art
Es sieht besser aus als wort art aber es sieht besser aus als wort art ok was haben wir hier zu bieten das da das ist einfach nur gelb
More text effects
Okay, ich muss euch sagen es ist mir tausend mal lieber als libra office
aber
Es ist einfach nur gelb
Okay, ich muss euch sagen es ist mir tausend mal lieber als libra office aber ich verwende überhaupt keine office geschichten
Deswegen werde ich das auch nicht verwenden
So
Aber ich finde man muss ganz ehrlich sagen das hat mich jetzt schon überzeugt irgendwie ihr wisst dass ich kritisch bin mal sowas ja und auch die
Letzten mal hatte ich immer was zu meckern und ich habe hier auch was zu meckern aber
Insgesamt muss ich sagen überzeugt mich das bisher schon das terminal gefällt mir allerdings nicht
Grün und dann hier grün copy paste und und wir können mal gucken was man da noch einstellen kann
Was benutzt du was benutzt du wenn man tabellen kalkulation braucht na ja wenn man programmieren kann
Braucht man in seltenen fällen tabellen kalkulationen wenn man doch wirklich tabellen kalkulationen braucht dann finde ich ist
Einer der wenigen
valid so
office anwendung scenarien
Excel
Das ist ok dafür kann man office verwenden das ist approved von mir dass man excel verwendet
Was schaut max gerade an die deep in china linux hier kann man hier eine unterschiedliches farbschirme einstellen
southern
Chat lesen ich bin bin nicht
Ja, aber das ist die lehrer fanden wird hat auch immer geil bei uns
Ja wir hatten wir hatten einen lehrer in
Können sogar sein dass das informatik hieß bei uns in der schule aber hatte mit informatik nichts zu tun das war ein bisschen den
wort rumgeklickt
Und der lehrer hat halt absolut keinen plan ja aber wie gesagt ich bin jetzt bei mir auch schon ein bisschen her mittlerweile sind die lehrer
Wahrscheinlich auch nicht besser und der konnte halt nichts der konnte ein bisschen wort machen und das lustige war
dass der
Dass du quasi immer da eins kriegen konntest wenn du die sachen lila gemacht hast
Ich weiß nicht ob der irgendwie bisschen
Kappa breit war oder so aber wenn du das lila gemacht hast da hat er sich immer gefreut hat immer gesagt leila leila leila es ist leila leila
Und dann hat er sich gefreut was da eins gekriegt
also
der eigentlich richtig pepega
Cheat 195 die
Dass das das gibt's die benino gibt es gibt schon seit zehn jahren oder so
also die werden immer fehler drin haben wenn die jetzt noch
Sein nach zehn jahren fehler drin aber ich meine ich meine es kommt ja auch immer neues dabei da kann schon mal ein bisschen was sein und
Guck dir mal windows an
Windows ist ja nur auch mal voll mit unkonsisten inkonsistenten
oberflächen
Macht es nicht besser ich weiß ja die oberflächen sind inkonsistent hier und ob sie das jetzt windows sind oder nicht macht es hier nicht besser
Aber sie sind aber weit nicht allein
So nur jono 3 1 2 3 4 das ist ja mal ein höchst kreativer
ritsch primen
Einen hochst kreativer benutzernahme ritsch primen dankeschön für den sub ich kann noch nicht richtig reden
big prime sub
Leila genau ja das war der halt
Was sind deine arbeitszeiten wenn man so fragen darf dienstags bis freitags von
ungefähr
6 uhr 50 bis 15 uhr 30
Und was sind deine arbeitszeiten wenn man so fragen darf dienstags bis freitags von
ungefähr
6 uhr 50 bis 15 uhr 30
Peinliche hafe ist der das zu früh das mache ich freiwillig ich könnte auch später kommen
Ich ich stehe gerne früh auf ich bin zwar müde dann auch irgendwo aber
Ich stehe eigentlich ganz gern da bin ich auch früher wieder daheim ja
Ok wichtigste ist die ist meine lieblingsschrift dabei das muss man noch mal nachgucken
Nein kein hack font ich brauche hack font heute hack
hack font
Ach ja wir müssen doch gucken wie installiert man hier eigentlich sachen app store
Ok ok moment mal heute es gibt einen package manager und es gibt einen app store
Wo es macht sound was ist man desktop verknüpfung alle anlegen
Der knäbler spammt die die sense sense hier rum
8 cent huge bitt
Wie lange brauchst du bis zur arbeit wenn man fragen darf
Ich brauche ziemlich genau
Halbe stunde oder sag einmal sagen wir von von
Ne stunde ich brauche eine stunde ungefähr ungefähr ich brauche eine stunde von tür zu tür allerdings
mit der halbe stunde laufen zwischendurch
Bei ich mache so wie sie stunden
ich brauche ziemlich genau halbe stunde oder sagen wir sagen wir von eine stunde ich brauche
eine stunde ungefähr ungefähr ich brauche eine stunde von tür zu tür allerdings mit
halbe stunde laufen zwischendurch also danke für die ganz piz kann ich mir noch kann ich mir
morgen brötchen kaufen kannst du mal auch bitte bald efft was ist efft efft linux efft was ist
efft linux efft es käme vom tag auf ich denke die ganze zeit es ist eine linux distribution die
efft heißt aber das ist battle royale battle royale ist wirklich nicht meins übrigens hier
das ist das ist fail das what the fuck ist kein battle royale also das was ich gesehen habe
sah sehr sah sehr battle royale loot mäßig aus ja ich stehe um fünf uhr ich stehe um fünf
uhr 45 auf und kurz nach sechs fahre ich mit dem zug und da bin ich so um sieben kurz vor sieben
ein bisschen nach sieben je nachdem je nachdem wie schnell ich bin und wie grün die ampeln sind bin
ich auf der arbeit aber das ist freiwillig ja also wenn ich wenn ich wirklich zug fahren würde
u-bahn fahren würde dann wäre in einer halben stunde halbe stunde bis 40 minuten oder halbe
stunde ziemlich genau halbe stunde wäre ich da weil ich ich wohne halt direkt gegenüber vom
bahnhof das ist halt kein ding und wenn ich frankfurt süd aussteige und mit der u-bahn
fahre dann dauert es halt auch noch mal fünf minuten da bin ich fast vor der haustür da
fünf vor 45 war fast was ich ob die das erlauben wahrscheinlich warum soll ich das nicht erlauben
die erlauben auch dass leute nachts arbeiten oder becker becker irgendwie um zwei uhr aufstehen
warum nicht ich mache das freiwillig wie gesagt können auch später arbeiten aber ich finde das
super dass ich um dass ich früh aufstehen kann und früh heim gehen kann ich sehe das ich sehe
das bei ganz vielen anderen kollegen auf der arbeit die sind dann da bis teilweise letzten ist
der eine der war bis 21 uhr da der ist halt irgendwie um zwölf oder um halb zwölf angerückt
war bis 21 oder irgendwie irgendwie leck lecken die bits ein bisschen kann das sein der knerbeer
hat es gebackt aber knerbeer wenn du weiter spams da muss ich leider die alle alle alle
bit notifications unter einem euro rausnehmen weil ansonsten plimp bimmelt er die ganze zeit
ich bete jetzt ich bete jetzt einfach das money hier und wir wollten gucken ob das deep in
terminal steams kann switch theme anscheinend wow ok leute das kann das kann er richtig viel
und es kann auch fast fast mein fast mein lieblings farbschema von haus aus ist nicht
ganz ich habe am liebsten tomorrow night tomorrow night 80s habe ich am liebsten aber ziemlich
ziemlich gut da da tomorrow night 80s aber das ist nicht tomorrow night 80s das ist fail so
sieht tomorrow night 80s nicht aus tomorrow night 80s ist das sieht anders aus ich habe
tomorrow night 80s jeden tag das sieht definitiv anders aus bis wann musst du arbeiten um
sieben anfangen 1530 aber ist das jetzt bald noch mal fertig also mein lieblings theme ist
dabei geht mir echt auf den keks jetzt jetzt jetzt ist jetzt ist live mag der max will kein
geld haben darf man das überhaupt auf twitter darf man mit benachrichtigung ausschalten wie
lange arbeitest du von der zeit effektiv egal was ich jetzt sage egal was ich jetzt sage es kann
gegen mich verwendet werden das ist eigentlich nice so kann man folgen voll das gelten muss
jetzt einfach noch ein paar mal sagen leute gleich schalte ich die cheer benachrichtigungen
aus wenn ihr nicht aufhört das ist eigentlich voll big brain einfach immer einfach immer sagen
oh nein kein kein kein keine bits mehr das ist übelst das ist übelst geld zu beten
30 sender big money der anonymos der anonymos cheerer guck mal der hat sogar der hat sogar
einen eigenen eigenen icon das ist ein twitch user ist ein twitch user ich vermute mal denke
mal das ist ein twitch user den die ganzen bezahlseiten verwenden wenn man eben bits
anonyme spendet okay jetzt reicht aber echt mal jetzt mache ich die jetzt mache ich die
benachrichtigungen wirklich mal aus wie geht das überhaupt ja da also alert box
alert box settings ja jetzt habe ich jetzt habe ich mich selbst benachrichtigt ja
hier bits
min die mindest bits mindest bits 100 save
so nachdem es fertig geküht ist sollte das eigentlich jetzt aufhören
ach so kann es sein dass man das noch einfügen muss jetzt neu
aber ich muss es jetzt neu einfügen das ist aber doof von steamlabs gemacht dass man
das jetzt neu einfügen muss mit den bits
na gut leute da muss ich euch mal kurz ausblenden oder doch ich blende ich blende euch trotzdem
aus weiß nie weiß nie was man da anzeigen sollte und was nicht
okay was auch immer das funktioniert nicht ich kann jetzt einfach noch ein bisschen
bisschen geld debaten was was passiert wenn ich bitte bitte als ausschalte
das geht
habe ich bitte lords aus
ich habe vorher zwar mindest bits eingestellt auf 100 aber das hat irgendwie nicht funktioniert
aber bitte lords wieder ein bitte lords wieder ein jetzt steht es auf 100 und jetzt hoffen
wir mal dass das funktioniert
es ist nur um das audio ich finde schon gut dass man das hört allerdings ist ein bit
Da kann er auch den ganzen Tag spammen, ist auch okay.
Ja, aber wenn ihr es hört, ist ja auch doof, dann wimmelt es bei euch die ganze Zeit.
Ja, Knäher, ja.
Debated!
Du kannst, du kannst es ja mal mit 100 probieren.
Oder, nein, 101, du musst es mit 101 probieren.
Weil ich hab ja mindest Bits, mindest Bits 100 eingestellt.
Und wenn das, wenn das quasi größer gleich ist, dann ist, äh, okay, aber wenn das größer ist, dann geht das nicht.
Heh-heh-heh, debated.
Genau.
Ähm, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Ich war, ich war, was irgendwo beizählen, über meine Arbeitszeiten, bevor wir uns die...
dass sie mal gucken wollten
Jemax fragt
kennst du einen beruf in der IT wo man eine gute Abwechslung hat
nahezu alle
wenn man kommt immer auf den laden an
hast du eigentlich witcher gespielt
ich hab alle witcher spiele gespielt
und bevor es fakeness war quasi
und ich muss sagen ich fand den dritten auch am besten
Teil 1, Teil 1 fand ich nur
meistens finde ich ja die ersten Teile fast mit am besten
Teil 1 war echt nicht übel
aber Teil 1 hat Geralt ein bisschen zu viel rumgefickt
ich mein Geralt ist da krasse Ficker
aber Teil 1 war ja teilweise an jeder Ecke
und du konntest in Teil 1 ja auch die Mädels sammeln und sowas
das war ein bisschen der Fokus komisch gelegt
genau bis wann musst du arbeiten wenn du um 7 anfängst
wie gesagt 15.30
15.30 das heißt
15.30
dann laufe ich zum Südbahnhof eine halbe Stunde
dass ich ein bisschen Bewegung hab am Tag
weil ich morgens eine halbe Stunde mittags eine halbe Stunde
es gibt Leute die freiwillig freitags nach 13 arbeiten
und bis 13.30
Solo, Yolo hab ich doch gemacht
99, ja 99 kann ich machen
das ist eine gute Idee ich hab mir das noch nie angeschaut
wie man Bits kauft
ich glaub ich hab noch nie im Leben Bits gekauft
ja 99 kann ich auch machen
testen wir mal ob es funktioniert
test test Bits
oh ich hab die
Leute hab ich die ganze Zeit das Display ausgehabt
hab ich die ganze Zeit das Display ausgehabt
sagt mal
ich hab die ganze Zeit schon weiter gemacht
ja
minus eins IQ
das ist richtig dumm
dachte ich hab's wieder eingeschaltet
so
hatte du heißt doch Max wer sagt das denn
morgen mal um 16 Uhr an den Südbahnhof stellen und Max rufen
kann es zu machen
Pock Knäherbär
Spamler
so
wo sind wir eigentlich jetzt bei der ganzen Geschichte stehen geblieben
nachdem wir uns genau wir wollten den App Store und den Package Manager uns mal angucken
warum vor allem warum gibt es da zwei verschiedene Sachen
das sieht ein bisschen aus
das sieht ein bisschen aus wie der Installer von Mac OS oder
Track and Drop Files hier
das ist das ist doch echt
das ganze Ding fühlt sich ein bisschen schon ein bisschen abgeguckt an an manchen Stellen
im Office im Office die die Bars oben sind eins zu eins von Microsoft geklaut
und der Installer hier auch wieder wieder aufgemacht ist
das sieht das sieht sehr Mac Style aus ja
finde ich auch weil wenn du wenn du wenn du unter Mac die Sache nicht aus dem App Store installierst
dann musst du die auch auf so einen Ordner track und droppen
Stream Delay
das waren drei Sekunden oder so
aber das ist das ist sehr Mac warum muss man jede Anwendung auf Darksteam stellen
obwohl man Darksteam ausgewählt hat
huge Uhrzeit
App Store gucken wir uns den App Store mal an
das ist jetzt
so was hätten die für die Witcher Serie immer brauchen können
das ist jetzt der normale
Gnome Packet Manager
Opera
Nee, das ist nicht der normale
da ist schon China Zeug drinne
weil Opera ist jetzt ja auch China
Rankings
ok
Disks
jetzt endlich kann man sich mal Festplatten downloaden
und ja auch mal Zeit
ja gut aber Team Viewer wenn Team Viewer drinne ist das ist garantiert nicht
die offiziellen Debian Quellen weil so gibt es für Team Viewer nicht
Team Viewer Flash
Flash
Kodi
Skype
ok das ist eine wilde Mischung Franz
was zum geier ist Franz
Meet Franz
und es gibt auch sogar Franz for Business
ist das irgendein chinesischer Skype Clone oder so
Ach eine Elektron ist es so ein Multimesenger oder was ist das
Ach hier
ok das ist so ein Multimesenger der irgendwie Whatsapp kann oder so anscheinend
hab ich noch nie gehört
Franz
man lernt nicht aus
aber warum ausgerechnet Franz
das ist eine wilde Mischung
Microsoft Office
ich würde sagen
das ist eine wilde Mischung
aus den normalen Debian Programm aus Open Source Programm und aus
Custom Paket Quellen
Team Viewer und Skype sind oder Skype oder Skype überhaupt da
oder habe ich jetzt übersehen
ist da
ist definitiv nicht in den Standard Debian Paket Quellen drin
Skype
ja Leute man kann Skype installieren
das ist auf jeden Fall nicht in den Standard Debian Paket Quellen drin
ich muss sagen ich finde das gar nicht so schlecht
ich mein Discord wenigstens ich finde eigentlich ist es vom Ansatz her ganz gut
eigentlich ist es vom Ansatz her doch ganz gut
man klickt einfach drauf
und man hat das was man haben will
was ist Whatsie
ohne dass man irgendwie Custom Mirror und sonst was hinzufügen muss
Non-Official Desktop Client for Whatsapp
aber ich bin der einzige Boomer der kein Whatsapp Account hat
Discord wie installiert man Discord
da müssen wir nicht fragen was es ist
wohin es installiert wird was
das ist bestimmt Snap oder wie jemand gerade entscheidet Flatpak oder sowas
also die mögen Sounds auf jeden Fall
Sounds sind huge
bei Deepin Linux
Discord
gucken wir mal wo Discord liegt
User Bin Discord
das sieht für mich fast aus wie eine ordentliche Installation auf Linux
Discord
sogar hier im Startmenü ist das drin
Screen Recorder
GIF
recordet das jetzt
Moment wie mache ich aus
so
das ist doch cool
I use Manjaro Linux
at work and private
private it's mainly
Windows because of games and video editing
I have always
Manjaro Linux VM
for network stuff and programming and at work I use exclusively Linux
Manjaro Linux
aber das ist cool da ist ein Screen Recorder dabei
das ist Deepin
Deepin hat vom Namen her ein bisschen
aber ich finde es cool dass sie einen Screen Recorder dabei haben der auch funktioniert
ich meine mir fällt gar keine Screen Recorder Software ein
für Linux
die ich nach installieren konnte da gibt es sehr wenig
das gefällt mir wirklich gut
Screenshot ist wahrscheinlich mehr oder weniger der gleiche
abbrechen
wir nehmen mal ein mp4 auf und gucken wir mal wie groß das ganze ist
zeig mal her
mp4 start
huge Fenster moving
eigentlich voll sick Bruder
huge Englisch skills
vor allem
wenn ich auf der Gamescom stotter ich mich da immer immer durch
aber das ist Übungssache es ist echt rein Übungssache ich merke das immer
wenn entweder wenn wir mal wieder einen haben der hauptsächlich Englisch redet
auf der Arbeit dann geht das auch nach ein paar Tagen
aber auf der Gamescom merke ich das immer
wenn ich da mal wieder hingehen würde ja aber
auf der Gamescom habe ich das immer gemerkt
am ersten Tag hat man sich übelst schwer getan danach ging es eigentlich
ist
das ist Gewöhnungssache Übungssache auch ein bisschen
wenn man sich im Kopf da wieder umgestellt hat
tatsächlich das funktioniert
das funktioniert einfach
einfach mal Screen recordern und gut ist
das ist das ist wirklich Pock
das gefällt mir
das kann man sogar das kann man wirklich angenehm benutzen
ja obs wird es
obs wird es nicht ersetzen
warum gibt es unter Windows eigentlich doch keinen gescheiten App Store wie unter Linux
ne unter Linux gibt es keinen App Store
das ist jetzt eine Deepin
Eigenheit hier
das ist eine Mischung
aus Paketen die das System mitbringt
bzw. die es offiziell aus den offiziellen Paketquellen gibt
und irgendwas von den Deepin Herstellern
also das ist kein wirklicher App Store
das haben sie App Store genannt
das ist eigentlich nur ein Frontend für den Paket Manager
man könnte jetzt natürlich fragen warum gibt es unter Windows keinen ordentlichen Paket Manager
und das frage ich mich auch schon seit langem
sie wollten sowas machen für Windows 10 haben sie aber nicht hingekriegt
und der App Store
und der Windows ist halt für'n Arsch
ja Michael das hab ich auch
das hab ich auch
ich muss manchmal übelst lang nachdenken mir fällt oft mal spontan das englische Wort an ein
und ich muss erstmal nachdenken wie es auf Deutsch heißt
ja Void Danny da ist nichts draus geworden und zwar war das hier
also NuGet gibt es ja schon ewig
die wollten Next Get oder so wie hieß das
ne
ähm
wie hieß das nochmal
Windows 10 Paket Manager
One Get
das wollten die mal einbauen in Windows 10
ok anscheinend wird das immer noch geupdated
aber
also ich hab davon
lange nichts mehr gehört
und anscheinend ist das auch nicht so das große Ding geworden
es gibt ein paar Ansätze von ein paar Trittanbieter Ansätze
es gibt hier
Choco gibt es, es gibt Scoop
aber das ist natürlich nichts im Vergleich zu nem Paket Manager offiziell mit offiziellen Quellen
wo auch viel drinne ist
das wäre natürlich das beste
deswegen mag ich ja Arch Linux so
weil du hast nen guten Satz aus Paketen und du hast mit User Repos
halt alles an Software was es irgendwie gibt
weißt du ob Deepin auch nach Hause telefoniert
kein Wissen tue ich das nicht
ähm
wie wahrscheinlich ist es
keine Ahnung
ich würde jetzt mal sagen macht es nicht
allerdings muss man sagen
so ne wirkliche Trennung in China
zwischen staatlichen Sachen und
was irgendwelche Unternehmen so machen
ist ja da
sagen wir mal etwas verschwommener
wie hierzulande
und
das kann auch gut sein dass es heimtelefoniert
Scoop nutze ich aber auch perfekt ist es nicht
ich muss euch sagen den besten Paket Manager muss ich sagen
es ist immer noch
immer noch
ein ordentlicher User Repo Manager
unter Arch Linux
so Dritten habe ich ja aktuell
vorher jahrelang den Joghurt benutzt den man ja nicht mehr benutzt
Dritten ist glaube ich das oder wie spricht man da ja auch
Dritten, Tryzen, keine Ahnung
das einzige Programm was in Perl geschrieben ist was ich
seit Jahren verwendet habe
und auch noch eine Weile verwenden werde
die meisten verwenden glaube ich J mittlerweile unter Arch Linux
ähm
ich muss aber sagen das ist mir am liebsten ich meine guck mal hier das da
das finde ich der beste Paket Manager
warte mal
mach mal an
habt ihr schon öfters gesehen aber vielleicht sind da nicht sehr manche Leute neu da
ähm
ja
Dritten da suchst du jetzt einfach nach was suchen wir jetzt denn zum Beispiel Firefox
Firefox
so
da kriegst du einfach erstmal alles wenn du einfach nur so simpel suchst
kriegst du einfach alles angezeigt
wo Firefox matcht
ich gebe jetzt zu das ist ein bisschen viel
ja man muss man halt hier durchgucken
oder man kann es halt filter man gibt halt ein bisschen was sinnigeres ein als einfach nur
Firefox
so und dann sage ich hier ok ich möchte Firefox installieren das ist die 1
und er installiert Firefox
easy
fertig
ich muss sagen das ist für mich
es ist Arch Linux mit dem User Repo Manager
ähm
das angenehmste was es gibt in der Richtung
ja und wir können jetzt hier auch mal sagen was passiert wenn wir hier nach Deepin suchen zum
Beispiel
finden wir alles was wir von Deepin Linux noch installieren könnten
wir könnten zum Beispiel hier auch dann unser
den Deepin
also immer installieren
Deepin Draw oder so
Wolltest du schauen wie groß die mp4 Datei ist? Ja wollte ich
also das ist mein Lieblingspaket Manager
wie groß ist die Datei? 2,3 MB ja gut das ist
normal für so ein
Video wo es kurz ist relativ kleine Auflösung und sich nichts bewegt
das ist ein Tech Attack Display
oh guck mal da
brauche ich zwar nicht aber warum nicht? Ja finde ich auch ganz gut
ähm
Windows 11 wird es nie geben oder?
damit da so ein Paket Manager implementiert werden könnte
doch
ähm
ich gehe fest davon aus dass Microsoft
neues Windows releaseen wird
ähm
ich kann es natürlich schlecht
predikten wann
mein Bauchgefühl sagt mir irgendwann dieses Jahr kommt die Ankündigung
weil
2020 passt einfach zu gut
und mich würde nicht wundern wenn Microsoft auch sagt wir machen jetzt Windows 20 nach Windows 10
aber auf der anderen Seite kann ich es mir nicht vorstellen
weil wenn
wenn die sowas machen würden
dann hätte man davon schon was mitgekriegt
100 pro hätte man man hätte es garantiert schon mit was mitgekriegt
aber ich mein guck mal Windows 20 wäre doch schon mal was oder?
oh warum nicht?
what language? It's German
German
he
Brutsch
ähm und es passt einfach zu gut 2020 als dass die da nichts machen
deswegen habe ich so die doofe Vermutung
dass sie ähm
es vielleicht dieses Jahr ankündigen 2020 passt einfach zu gut
aber ich gehe fest davon aus es gibt ein neues Windows
nicht nicht vielleicht dieses Jahr vielleicht doch nicht nächstes Jahr aber Microsoft wird was machen weil
und äh ich finde ich finde das liegt irgendwie auf der Hand
diese Windows as a Service Geschichte
funktioniert muss man sagen ist auch eine gute Sache wie Microsoft das ganz macht
mit kontinuierlichen Updates
ähm
aber man muss auch ehrlich sagen
so gut wie so ein Rolling Release beispielsweise unter Arch Linux oder
oder ähm halbjährliche Updates mit Ubuntu
so gut die da funktionieren ich mein
ich hatte auf meinem Ubuntu auf keinem Ubuntu Server je Probleme mit dem Update
ähm weder noch noch auf dem Desktop wo ich das verwendet habe
mit Windows 10 Updates sieht es ganz anders aus
und so richtiges Rolling Release ist es ja eigentlich auch nicht
ähm und ich hatte auch mit Rolling Release bei Manjaro sehr wenig Probleme im Vergleich zu Windows Updates
und ich finde
dass Microsoft das grundsätzlich richtig macht aber die haben so viele Probleme mit der Update Geschichte
und es ist so viel
halbgares drinne in Windows 10
ähm
dass ich fest davon ausgehe
die arbeiten schon daran
das
grundlegend einheitlicher zu machen und grundlegend
besser zusammenzuführen
und das ist dann nichts was man in einem halbjahres Update bringt
also ich gehe fest davon aus
auch wenn sie sagen Windows Accessories ich gehe fest davon aus
dass es eine neue Windows Version geben wird
genauso wie es dann dementsprechend auch eine neue Windows Server Version geben wird
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass der
wo ist denn jetzt los
bitte hier gestoppt ohne Ende ich könnte mir vorstellen dass der
Umstieg
dann oder das Upgrade von Windows 10 auf sag mal 20
dass das dann relativ einfach sein wird
oder vielleicht sogar
vielleicht
vielleicht ist es sogar so
dass das das so quasi
in Rahmen eines eines Live Updates oder irgendwie so passiert
passieren könnte
also die Live Update also nicht im laufenden Betrieb sondern quasi so
so on the fly von Windows 10 auf Windows 20
so dass es quasi wie ein Update ist
aber da ich gehe fest von aus dass es ein neues Windows geben wird
äh wen haben wir denn hier?
Roffle 143
ne 1436 Switch Prime
Big Brain Big Prime
äh wen haben wir denn sonst noch?
der Michael hat dem neuen Tester mir ein Stufe 1 Abo geschenkt
huge sub bzw. huge gift ist es ja
dann haben wir als nächstes äh
The Hook Twitch Prime
5 Monate
Aja Jahre
wir haben leider keine Piraten Smileys
ja danke Michael für die 2 schon 2 gegifteten Amos
dann haben wir
Snicklust
äh nennt mich ein bisschen an Nicklas
so hieß unser Special
Mega Azumi
den wir mal hatten
äh
Snicklust
2 Monate danke schön für den Sub
Ice Freak ist auch wieder da den Namen kann ich nicht mehr merken
weil das mal ein ordentlicher verliebt speakter Name ist
den man auch gut lesen kann
huge subs alles hier
wen haben wir da sonst noch?
das wars jetzt
das wars schon
Leute was ist da los?
kann nicht sein
ich will jetzt noch ein paar subs vorlesen
äh ist WPS freeware?
ähm
ich hab keine Ahnung
irgendeine China Software
ich glaube ich glaube
ich weiß nicht ob sie so open source ist glaube ich nicht aber sie ist kostenlos ja
also kostet nichts
äh
ähm
genau Tom das denke ich auch
ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen
ähm
dass die
das Upgrade
von Windows 10 auf Windows 20
dass das nahezu umsonst sein wird
wenn es überhaupt was kostet
aber wie gesagt ich gehe fest davon aus die arbeiten an irgendwas
TF Leute was ist jetzt hier los?
gehts aber ab
aiaiai
aiaia besser gesagt
ähm
Deasykiller
hat Abos verschenkt
und zwar
wen haben wir denn jetzt hier am Start?
ähm
erstmal danke für die 5
huge massive brain subs
ne nicht prime
ähm
wir haben hier den Maximiliano27
der Eichelris Underscore
ganz wichtig
dass da ein Underscore drinne hat
Eichelris allein war wahrscheinlich schon belegt ne
der Noobrunner
Weigeros und Kvai
hat auch wieder was gekriegt
huge
wahnsinnig big brain subs
das Ratchet verschenkt auf 5 Stück
ähm
insgesamt sogar schon 10 Stück
ein PC lustig ein Monster
8 5 7 0 und
pragmatic Lu
Wasserfreak
und Plooscream
weil das ist Plooscream ist ein cooler Name
die
Nähe zu Plooscream
ist unverkennbar
Dankeschön für die ganzen subs
huge subs
big subs massive subs
Michael
das ist ja alles
wie gesagt ich bin froh auch einfach alle die da sind
und zugucken
hab die Kohle nicht nötig
und äh
ich freu mich das immer so viele Leute bei
so ner Nischengeschichte wie bei meinem
äh Stream was wir hier machen ist jetzt ja nicht so
dass das äh halb Deutschland
interessiert wird der immer am Start sind
und das mittlerweile wohlgemerkt ohne YouTube
Promotion
ohne Twitch Promotion äh ohne
Twitter Promotion oder irgendwas
einfach nur
durch
ohne
unregelmäßige Streams
äh die Musik
die Musik ist
komisch aber Chill Step Stream
das zufälligerweise
gerade wieder von vorne angefangen
das hatten wir doch
das hat gerade wieder von vorne angefangen oder
das hatten wir vorher schon auf
das ist Epic
Chill Step Collection
Epic
hört sich ziemlich normal an
ehrlich gesagt für mich aber wenn die sagen
das ist Epic
Reptile Hunter
4 Monate am Start
Dankeschön
Huge Sub
Wer haben wir da sonst noch?
Ich sollte öfters mal sagen
dass ich gerne Subscriber vorlesen würde
das scheint ja echt gut zu helfen
zu helfen
Twitch Prime
der Hubi
Train Sub lets go
Train Sub geht auch
Train Sub haben wir hier auch zu bieten
ich hab keine Donate
man kann nicht mehr donaten
easykiller geht nicht mehr
kanns dir vorstellen
ich kann mir zu ganz vielen Sachen vorstellen
Video aufzunehmen
vorstellen kann ich mir viel
das Problem ist wenn ich mir das vorstelle
sag ich mal
das ist auch nicht aus dem Wörterbuch
Lizenzufuchs
kuckt euch das mal an
ich weiß jetzt nicht ob Lizenzufuchs
einfach nur ein super
Big Brain Name ist
für so einen Händler
oder ob Lizenzufuchs
irgendein China Scam Mars ist
der es aus dem Wörterbuch hat
ich tippe einfach mal drauf
und gut gewählt. Lizenzfuchs gefällt mir irgendwie. Wer ist denn der Lizenzfuchs?
Lizenzfuchs? Guck mal hier. Ich meine bei EDK ist es billiger,
aber der Lizenzfuchs scheint legit zu sein. Aber vor allem warum ist der Marvino aus 20 gelistet?
Auf eBay einfach einen Key für 2 Euro kaufen. Ich habe schon ein paar Windows Keys gekauft,
die alle nicht funktioniert haben. Also ich habe mich schon ein paar mal scammen lassen,
aber leider auch immer nur 1 für 1,50 oder so. Aber beim Lizenzfuchs, da hast du ja wahrscheinlich
auch ordentlich, wenn es nicht geht schicken sie dir bestimmt einen neuen. Ich sollte Lizenzfuchs
mal anschreiben, ob ich nicht sie anpreisen soll und kriege dann die Hälfte davon ab. Tom 712
Stufe 1 ein richtig echter. Kein, sondern ein richtig echter. Sehr nice. Wo was bezieht ihr
denn auf der Arbeit für Windows 10 Lizenz? Das weiß ich nicht, da habe ich nichts mit zu tun.
Man könnte man könnte auch bei EDK, man kann ja auch bei EDK Windows 10 kaufen. PC Fritz,
ja, das habe ich ja schon ganz vergessen. Ja gut, was auch immer. Leute, wir haben uns
wieder ultra krass sidetracken lassen. Was wollen wir uns denn noch? Wir müssen uns ein paar
Sachen angucken hier unter deep in Linux. Wir haben uns den App Store angeguckt. Was haben
die sonst noch dabei im Movie? Man kann Videos schneiden. Da bin ich jetzt ja mal gespannt.
Kann Videos schneiden? Die Ladegeschwindigkeit ist sehr, Moment, das ist fertig geladen. Ich
dachte, ich dachte, das ist der Splash Screen. Kein Cutter, das ist ein Video Player. Verstehe,
das ist ein Video Player. Ich dachte, das ist sowas wie der Movie Maker. Ist es aber nicht.
So, dann suchen wir mal nach deep in. Was empfiehlt er? Der deep in Editor. Ob das was ist? Okay,
das ist ein Notepad im Endeffekt. Das ist ein Notepad. Ein bisschen Cute String. Ein bisschen
inkonsistent ist es ja schon, weil die Themes beispielsweise, die es im Text Editor gibt
und im Terminal gibt und im User Interface gibt, alle ein bisschen anders heißen und hier
ist es beispielsweise nicht dark. Guck mal, hier ist beispielsweise das ganze hell, obwohl
hier mein File Explorer dark ist. Also so hundertprozentig stimmig ist das Ganze noch nicht. Kann
man C-Sonntags machen. Na, es ist zumindest ein bisschen besserer Editor als manch anderem
Sachen dabei ist. Was ist denn das about? Deep in Editor. Es ist auf jeden Fall besser
als Notepad. Was haben wir denn sonst noch dabei? Ein Manual, das ist ein bisschen chinesisch.
Deep in Store. Deep in Image View. Hier sieht man alles, was es gibt. Deep in Editor. Das
ist auch schon mal gut, dass die haben tatsächlich ein komplett englisches Handbuch dabei. Deep
in System Monitor. Guck mal, das ist ein Taskmanager. Im Endeffekt ist es ein Taskmanager. Ist aber
auch gut, dass so was dabei ist. Wenn die Bros, die schießen die ganzen Sachen irgendwie
so ab. Und dann mit Kill. Aber so ein Taskmanager ist bestimmt nicht verkehrt. Für Noobs. Fullscreen.
Exit Fullscreen. Okay, was kann man sonst noch hier schönes einstellen? Up to the system
information. Finde das sieht nicht schlecht? Ja, finde ich auch. Also ich muss euch ehrlich
sagen, war dann im Store auch Spotify. Also ich muss sagen, von allen Linux Sachen, die
wir bisher im Stream ausprobiert haben, muss ich sagen, bewirkt das Interface. Ich meine,
das wird auch eine Chrome, eine Chrome, was ist denn für ein Schwachsinn, eine Gnome-Chell-Geschichte
sein hier. Aber von allen Sachen, die wir bisher getestet haben, finde ich das eigentlich
ganz schick. Spotify. Ja guck mal, sogar Spotify ist drinne. Good App, Free Music. Aber das
telefoniert nach Hause, wahrscheinlich schon. Man weiß es nicht. Oh, das will das, das ist
nice. Das behalten wir. Das behalten wir jetzt. Mama-Wahl und Baby-Wahl. Was ist das hier,
der Audio-Player? Das sieht alles doch ganz brauchbar aus. Muss ich jetzt echt sagen.
Das sieht schon brauchbar aus, was die Chinesen hier gebaut haben. Ein bisschen inkonsistent
ist es, wie wenn man hier speichert zum Beispiel, dass es dann kein Dark Theme ist und so. Okay,
das kann man ja noch alles ganz machen. Aber alles in allem gefällt mir das eigentlich
ganz gut. Was müssen wir noch gucken? Also, gut, das hier muss ich nicht ausprobieren,
das ist ein Debian Stable drunter. Wir können mal gucken, was für eine VS Code Version
drinne ist. Das ist tatsächlich nicht schlecht. 1.3.6. Okay, das ist schon ein bisschen ältere
Version. Wahrscheinlich die Debian Stable Version oder so. 1.3.6 ist schon ein bisschen
älter, oder? Oder was ist denn? 1.4.1 ist aktuell, oder? Warte mal. Chat, ihr wisst
das doch bestimmt. 1.4.2. Ja, das ist schon ein bisschen älter. Aber das wundert mich
nicht. Es ist halt... Huge. Scheiner. Es ist halt Debian Stable. Debian Stable ist nun
mal alt. Das heißt, den anderen Kram müssen wir gar nicht gucken. Wir wissen, dass es
im Prinzip... Es ist ein Debian Stable mit ein paar Custom-Sachen. Aber es ist schon...
Nutzt ihr selbst, oder am Ende Flatpak oder Snap? Ich vermute mal, das ist eine Mischung
aus allem. Also, solche Sachen hier sind wahrscheinlich ganz normal aus den Debian-Paketquellen, sowas
hier. Das da zum Beispiel. Das wird ganz normal aus den Paketquellen kommen von Debian,
denke ich mal. Aber so Sachen wie Opera, TeamView und Flash, das könnte schon sowas wie Snap
oder Flatpak sein. Wobei ich sagen muss, wir haben Discord installiert. Discord liegt
zumindest schon mal nicht... Ist schon mal zumindest kein Snap. Mal gucken, ob Snap installiert
ist. Achtung hier. Oh, das hat keinen Sound. Aber das hat einen Sound. Auf Desktop hat
keinen Sound. Und gucken wir uns mal den Mülleimer an. Guck mal, hier oben leert man den MT.
All die stehen auf Sounds. Die Chinesen. Die stehen auf Sounds. Das habe ich schon gemerkt.
Disk. Ah, das ist die CD. Kann man nicht auswerfen. Das ist Netzwerk. Hier kann man ausschalten.
So, und jetzt gucken wir mal. Flat. Snap. Weder noch. Oder, gut, es kann auch sein,
dass es nicht im Fad drin ist. Dass sie das intern verwenden. Kann schon sein. Aber ehrlich
gesagt juckt mich das gar nicht so großartig, solange es so funktioniert, wie ich es erwarte.
Also ich finde es echt gut. Es ist auch bemerkenswert, dass die einzige Distribution, die ich kenne,
die Chrome vorinstalliert hat. Den echten, keinen Chromium. Echten, echten Chrome. Und
zwar Version. Version. Was haben wir hier? Das ist die aktuelle, ne? Die aktuelle Version.
Das ist die aktuelle. Die kam aber erst vorgestern raus. Okay, so schnell sind sie hier noch
nicht. Aber es ist definitiv neuer als dem hier an Stable. Was ist eigentlich für eine
Standard-Suchmaschine drin? Google. Das ist Deep in Linux. China OS. Also insgesamt kann
ich sagen, wenn man einen grafischen Desktop haben will. Und der gut zu bedienen ist auch
für Noobs. Da muss ich euch ehrlich sagen, rein vom Oberflächenkonzept her gefällt
mir das bisher. Mit Abstand am besten. Deep in Linux. Also tief rein Linux. Weiß nicht,
was sie sich bei dem Namen gedacht haben. Ja. Pursi. Wie gesagt, Deep in Linux. Was ist
denn Windows Power Toys? Wie seid ihr denn jetzt von Deep in Linux auf Windows Power
Toys gekommen? Hast du schon mal den Wireshark angeschmissen? Ne, hab ich nicht. Wobei wir
müssten ja den Wireshark eigentlich vom Haus-System anschmeißen. Jaja. Huge traffic. Aber wenn
ich mein Traffic, das ist OBS, das ist mein ganzer Traffic zu Twitch, muss was doch hier
drin anschmeißen. Aber das geht nicht. Wenn ich die Wireshark-Version hier davon installiere,
dann ist die Wireshark-Version aus dem China Linux bestimmt so gepatcht, dass die das China
Linux Zeug nicht anzeigt. Ich glaube, das ist... Guck, das verfolge ich jetzt nicht weiter.
Ich hab halt auch so ein bisschen Bauchgefühl, also ein bisschen schlechtes Bauchgefühl
bei, den China Linux zu verwenden. Aber trotzdem muss ich sagen, ich mein ganz ehrlich, Leute
verwenden auch ein Chromebook und sowas. Rein vom Benutzerkonzept hat mich es aber wirklich
überzeugt. Verwenden würde ich es nicht, aber ich würde auch kein anderes Linux verwenden,
außer eben Manjaro mit i3-WM als Desktop-IP-Dig. OMFG, Alter. Jetzt ist es raus. Ich hab ne
IP. Linux Mint. Ja, Linux Mint kann man auch verwenden. Linux Mint ist auch nicht verkehrt.
Aber ich muss sagen, wenn wir jetzt mal ausblenden, dass es ein China Linux ist, weil man könnte
auch Redstar OS verwenden aus Nordkorea, aber wenn wir mal ausblenden, dass es ein China
Linux ist, ist das von allen Linux-Distributionen, die wir uns bisher zusammen im Stream angeguckt
haben, die sich unter anderem auch an Einsteiger richten, das Beste. Also ich glaube, damit
kommen die Leute gut klar. Was ich auch cool finde ist, dass hier dieses komische was auch
immer, das WPS-Office, WPS-Office scheint mir nämlich auch gut benutzbar zu sein für
die Noobs. Das sieht original aus wie Powerpoint. Ja. Also immer. Das sieht original aus wie
Powerpoint. Das ist für die Windows-Noobs ist das toll. Hier gibt es so einen komischen
Excel-Klon hier. Das sieht original aus wie Excel, ja. Und es funktioniert wahrscheinlich
besser und angenehmer als LibreOffice. Würdest du empfehlen, wenn man mit Programmieren beginnt
auf Linux umzusteigen? Nein. Weil ich würde prinzipiell nie empfehlen, wenn man was anfängt
zu lernen, gleichzeitig noch eine andere Sache zu machen. Ist im Prinzip auch so, wenn ich
eine neue Programmiersprache lerne, dann baue ich damit nicht eine Web-Anwendung, wo ich
einen Frontend-Framework einsetze, was ich auch noch nie eingesetzt habe. Man sollte immer
eine Sache auf einmal machen und du kannst auch ohne Probleme, es gibt ganz viele Leute,
die programmieren ausschließlich unter Windows und da funktioniert das auch. Und je nachdem,
was du programmieren möchtest, ist Windows auch die bessere Plattform. Alles in allem
kann ich aber sagen, es programmiert sich meiner Meinung nach, wenn man jetzt nicht
Windows-spezifische Sachen programmiert, programmiert es sich meiner Meinung nach
unter Linux besser. Nichtsdestotrotz kann man das unter Windows genauso gut machen. Eine
Sache, die beispielsweise unter Linux einfach viel angenehmer ist als unter Windows, ist
ein ordentliches Terminal zu haben. Dass du Sachen wie Telnet, SSH und alle möglichen
Kommando-Zeilen-Tools halt standardmäßig drauf hast. Du kannst beispielsweise auch super
natürlich Remote auf dem Raspberry Pi ohne Monitor was machen über SSH. Solche Sachen
sind unter Linux angenehmer, je nachdem, was man macht. Das würde ich auch bevorzugen.
Aber umgedreht gibt es auch Anwendungsfälle, zum Beispiel Windows-Desktop-Anwendung. Da
ist es natürlich schon anders unter Windows zu machen. Man kann theoretisch Windows-Desktop-Anwendungen
unter Linux entwickeln. Ganz, ganz krückenmäßig. Aber nur alte Windows-Forms-Geschichten.
Aber es ist halt nicht schön. Ja, wenn du Spiele programmieren willst, würde ich nach
wie vor auch das unter Windows machen. Allein schon aus dem Grund, weil die meisten Leute
unter Windows sitzen, die deine Spiele später spielen werden. Wobei man sagen muss, ich
denke, wie gesagt, ich denke, ich weiß es nicht. Hab ich noch nicht gemacht. Aber ich
denke, wenn man Spiele anfängt, dann nimmt man heute wahrscheinlich eh zum größten Teil
Unity. Vor allem, wenn man eh schon.NET-Entwickler ist und sich mit sie scharf auskennt. Und
ich glaube, dass es mit Unity ganz gut möglich ist, Spiele cross-Plattformen zu machen,
dass die theoretisch unter Linux und unter Windows laufen. Vor allem, wenn es halt jetzt
nicht so die absolute Pleading-Edge-Grafik-Custom-Dinger braucht. Sondern wenn man mit dem Standard-Unity-Zeug
auskommt. Aber ich weiß nicht, ich hab von Spielen keine Ahnung. Programmiertechnisch.
Eine KI auch auf Windows. Ja, KI ist so eine Sache, wenn du das mit TensorFlow machen willst
und Python. Kann man unter Windows machen. Das finde ich unter Linux beispielsweise viel
angenehmer. Und spätestens, wenn du die Sache eh in Zukunft auch auf Linux laufen lassen
möchtest. Und so Machine-Learning-Sachen hören sich ja ein bisschen danach an, als
willst du das auf einem Server laufen lassen und das es dann halt da vor sich hin werkelt,
dann würde ich es auch unter Linux entwickeln. Es bietet sich in der Regel immer an die Anwendung
unter dem Betriebssystem zu entwickeln, wo sie auch am Ende läuft. So naheliegend es
klingt. Programmierst du was, was hauptsächlich unter Linux laufen soll oder auf irgendeinem
Server laufen soll, was gar auf einem Raspberry laufen soll, dann musst du das unter Linux
machen. Weil es ist beispielsweise auch viel einfacher unter Linux was zu cross-compile.
Also sprich, dass du es auf deinem Desktop kompilierst für einen Raspberry, wie das
unter Windows ist. Man muss immer gucken, was man machen will. Meiner Meinung nach ist
es blöd pauschal zu sagen, man sollte das eine oder das andere nehmen, weil das eher
dazu führt, dass man sich da in irgendwelchen ideologischen Sachen verrennt, so nach dem
Motto der Editor ist besser als der, das Betriebssystem ist besser als der, was auch immer. In Wirklichkeit
geht es einem ja darum, ein bestimmtes Problem ordentlich und sinnvoll zu lösen. Und da
ist es eigentlich kaum förderlich, wenn man sagt, es muss diese Editor verwendet werden,
es muss diese Programmiersprache verwendet werden, es muss dieses Framework verwendet
werden. Das würde ich immer davon abhängig machen, was man eigentlich programmieren
will. Und selbst, wenn man auf die Idee kommt, dass Java die beste Variante ist, dann soll
man es halt mit Java machen. Warum nicht? Kennst du dich mit Low-Code-Plattform aus?
Du meinst jetzt nicht Low-Level, sowas wie Mikro-Controller, ESP oder noch niedriger.
Was ist Low-Code? Ist das? Für Low-IQ-Programmierer. Also ich habe von Low-Coding mit Track-and-Drop
für Noobs, das ist Schwachsinn. Programmieren mit Track-and-Drop, das ist nix halbes und
nix ganzes, das ist Schwachsinn. Braucht kein Mensch. Spackhack, vier Monate, dankeschön.
Big Prime, Big Prane-Sub. Wieso Java, wenn man es in Sharp verwenden kann? Vielleicht
wenn man in China ist. In China ist Java übelst angesagt. Wenn man Cross-Plattform-Wii-Framework
haben will und nicht Qt oder Electron verwenden will, kann man auch Java verwenden. Haben
sie ja noch nicht hingekriegt bei Microsoft. Wenn es Libraries gibt, die es nur für Java
gibt, muss man auch Java verwenden. Aber ich habe letztens ein Projekt gesehen, wo jemand
die Standard-Java-Class-Library und die Standard-Java-Standard-Library in.NET nachgebaut hat und dann irgendwie
ein bisschen Magic gemacht hat. Man kann dann quasi Java in.NET verwenden und so ganz
abgedrehtes Zeug. Die Leute gehen ab. Hast du ein gutes Buch für AI-Programmierung? Nee.
Wo holst du Informationen? Es ist unterschiedlich. Kommt ein bisschen auf die Programmiersprache
an. Also mittlerweile muss ich sagen, ich starte meistens, wenn ich irgendwas Neues lernen will,
ich starte meistens mit der YouTube-Suche und gucke mir auf YouTube so einen Mini-Hallo-Welt-Guide
an von irgendwas Neuem. Das ist eigentlich immer das Erste, was ich mittlerweile mache,
wenn ich was Neues lerne. Ich gucke jemandem auf YouTube zu, der ein bisschen was Kleines
da drin baut. So fange ich meistens an und dann weiß ich schon so grob, was ich brauche,
was ich mache und dann wird halt einfach rund um die Uhr gegoogelt, bis man halbwegs fit
ist in der jeweiligen Sprache oder dem jeweiligen Framework. Zu 99% wird eh gegoogelt, am besten
in Bing googeln oder googeln in DuckDuckGo. Was kommt in UN zum Einsatz, wo die IT überfordert
ist und Abteilung Business-Anwendung benötigen, die dann selbst erstellen? Also ganz ehrlich,
Track-and-Drop-Programmierung ist einfach für'n Arsch. Das ist nichts halbes und nichts
ganzes. Ja, ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es quasi für die Noobs irgendwie toll ist,
sich da ein bisschen was zusammenzuklicken, aber du kannst keine komplexe Logik ordentlich
Track-and-Drop zusammenklicken. Da reicht ja alles Papier der Welt nicht aus, wenn man
was drucken will. Das wird riesengroß. Deswegen bin ich auch kein Fan von Node-RED. Node-RED
ist so'n Aufsatz für Heimautomatisierung, wo man sich quasi seine Automatisierung hier
so zusammenklicken kann. Wenn das nur ein bisschen komplexer wird, ist das einfach riesengroß
und unwartbar irgendwie so. Und ich behaupte mal, dass es viele Konstrukte gibt, die man
in einer ordentlichen Programmiersprache relativ kurz und knackig lösen kann, was ein riesen
Act ist in irgendwelchen GUI-Track-and-Drop-Sprachen. Oder Editors, wie auch immer man das nennt.
Chaotix sagt, studiere Informatik. Programmieren in vielen Sprachen ganz okay. Viel Unikram
halt. Wie wird wohl später der Berufseinstieg? Wirklich Praxis, produktnahe Programmierungen
macht man ja kaum, hast du ne Ahnung. Kommt auf den Laden an, wo du hingehst. Ich mein,
es spricht ja nix dagegen, dass du ein bisschen praktische Sachen machst, oder? Also ich
mein, letztendlich ist jeder Programmierer, die Leute heben das immer, immer so krass
hervor, auch auf YouTube so nach dem Motto. Self-taught Programming oder selbst beigebrachtes
Programmieren. Jeder, der Programmieren gelernt hat, hat es selbst gelernt. Man lernt kein
Programmieren durch zu gucken. Jeder ist selbst gelernter Programmierer. Alle. Und
das heißt, das Beste ist, du suchst dir irgendein Projekt, was dich interessieren muss, das
muss ja nix großartiges sein, ja. Ein paar Kleinigkeiten, am besten irgendwas, was dich
halt wirklich interessiert, beziehungsweise da, wo du vielleicht auch das Gefühl hast,
die Software, die es aktuell gibt, die nervt dich oder irgendwie ist nicht so hundertprozentig
wie du es haben willst. Es können wirklich simple Sachen sein. Mach so ein Notizprogramm
oder sowas. Ich bin immer noch dabei, es gibt kein ordentliches Notizprogramm. Oder
mach den Klassiker, mach den Klassiker, mach ne To-Do-Liste. Das Hallo-Welt der Programmierer.
Mach ein To-Do-Listen-Programm, so wie du es dir gerne vorstellst. Halt mit der Technologie,
die dir Spaß macht, wo du denkst, hey, das ist das, was ich später machen will oder
das, was mir gefällt oder wo ich mich mit auskenne. Oder such dir halt ein ordentliches Projekt
raus und dann kannst du ja auch so vorher schon ein bisschen Erfahrung sammeln. Du musst
ja nicht warten, bis du dann irgendwo mal im Büro sitzt und zu dir einer sagt, so nach
dem Motto, auf geht's, jetzt wird programmiert und du sagst, äh, äh, wie denn? Gut, mal
ganz davon abgesehen. Ähm, die fragen dich natürlich vorher auch schon und vielleicht
kommst du dann auch gar nicht in die Nähe raus, weil wenn du halt sagst, ja gut, theoretisch
kann ichs, praktisch kacke ich ab beim Programmieren. Ich würde mir irgendwas Kleines suchen und
ein bisschen rum basteln. Ja, neues Testament, genau, das ist das Problem. Wenn du Programmlogik
in irgendwelchen grafischen Editoren machst, das ist halt riesengroß, auch für ganz kleines
Zeug, das ist riesengroß. Wohnt sie nicht. Ja, ja, ja, ja, mecker, meckers, ähm, der
Unreal Script Editor, das ist ein bisschen was anderes, weil du hast ja da sehr viel
Logik im Hintergrund, also du hast quasi schon einzelne, das ist ein bisschen wie in Unity,
wenn du Sachen track und drops. Du track und drops da ja nicht irgendein Icon, wo du dann
quasi die Funktion implementierst, sondern das, was du in dem Unity oder dem Unreal Editor
track and drops, da ist ja schon Logik dahinter, also da ist ja, da sind quasi Snippets, wenn
du es so willst, die du zusammen linkst. Das ist ja nicht die komplette Logik, äh, in
track und drop zusammengebaut, weil das wäre viel zu groß, sondern es ist quasi schon
einzelne fertig programmierte Bausteine genommen und sie ein bisschen miteinander verknüpft,
aber trotzdem, ich hab schon ein paar Leute zugeguckt, die, ähm, wie heißt das, heißt
das Blueprint Editor in Unreal? Ich glaub, das heißt irgendwie, wie gesagt, hab von Spiel
relativ wenig Plan, ähm, und ich hab mir da ein paar Streams angeguckt, da hat einer
diesen Unreal Script Editor da verwendet, dieses grafische Ding, wo man da Boxen miteinander
legen, ey, der Typ, da ist der Path of Exile Skilltree nix dagegen, das war so krass komplex
GUI Zeug, was der Typ da hatte, wo ich mir gedacht hab, ey, hättest du das mal Sourcecode
mäßig ordentlich strukturiert und von Hand programmiert, dann, äh, wär das deutlich
übersichtlicher und besser gewesen. Ähm, Michael, ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht,
ich, äh, kann, also ich weiß, dass ich irgendwie verschiedene Sachen hinzufügen kann, aber
ob ich dir die Faults-Sachen ändern kann, keine Ahnung, aber ich glaube, ich kann die,
ich kann die Punktzahl anpassen, ich glaube, ich kann die Punktzahl anpassen, wie teuer
was ist. Hast du in Richtung KI-Programmieren drauf, Max? Nee. Ist ein Bereich, der mich
jetzt bis jetzt noch nicht großartig interessiert hat, das einzige, was wir mal letztens im
Steam gemacht haben, was vielleicht ansatzweise, aber höchstens ansatzweise in die Richtung
geht, eigentlich auch schon nicht, wir haben ein bisschen Bilderkennung gemacht, ähm,
Bewegungserkennung in Überwachungskamera-Bildern, das hat mit KI eigentlich auch nix zu tun.
Nee, denn das finde ich nicht, finde ich nicht, das ist ein bisschen, wie wenn man erzählt
kriegt, so nach dem Motto, mal deinen Programmcode in einem Struktogramm. Das ist auch Blödsinn,
Struktogramme sind komplett für'n Arsch. Der Friseur streamt, was ist da los? Hab ich
ja eh nicht einmal gesehen, dass der on war. Äh, okay, Mecker, Mecker, ich glaube, das
war jetzt relativ lang, was war denn da deine Frage? Achso, ey, muss ich mal kurz zurückspulen,
ich hab da jetzt irgendwie 10 Minuten drüber gelabert oder so. Ja Diablo, schön, dass du
immer noch am Start bist. Ist jetzt grad relativ unspektakulär, ich sitz hier da, mache nix
und laber mit dem Chat, ja, das kommt öfters mal vor, vor allem kurz bevor ich off gehe,
ich bin jetzt ja auch gleich weg. Ähm, aber schön, dass du eine Wege hier ja gefunden
hast. Das, das ist übrigens der Grund, einer der Gründe, warum ich hier anders heiße und
keine großartige Werbung auf YouTube mach, weil ich die Erfahrung gemacht hab, dass die
Leute, die es von alleine hier her finden, auch die richtigen Leute sind. Weil es gibt
auf YouTube schon viele der... Struktogramme, ja, tschüss, mein Hemd. Struktogramme ist
der größte Shit überhaupt. Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, warum man diesen Blödsinn
den Leuten noch beibringt. Sogar der Struktogramm Erfinder hat ein paar Jahre später gesagt
Schwachsinn. Wir mussten bei unserer Abschlussprüfung
heart and mind auf Papier schreiben. Wann war denn das, Captain Siegheim? Wie lange ist
denn das her? Kannst du ein gutes Einsteigerbuch empfehlen oder bringt das überhaupt nichts
und springt einfach mit dem Kopf ins Wasser? Doch, doch, doch. Bücher kann ich empfehlen,
also generell kann ich empfehlen, sich ein Programmierbuch zu holen. Wenn man jemand
ist, der halt gerne Schwanz auf weiß, was ich sag mal, hat, das ist doch schon besser
aufbereitet als beispielsweise irgendwie so die Getting Started Anleitung auf den offiziellen
Seiten. Ein gutes Pilsen Buch für gerade für AI Programmierung kann ich dir allerdings
nicht empfehlen. Ich kann Ihnen ein ganz gutes Pilsen Buch empfehlen und zwar, wie hieß
denn das? Das habe ich mir auch gekauft vor Jahren. Muss mal kurz gucken. Das ist so lange
her, dass Amazon es doch nicht mal mehr findet. Aber wenn ich das Cover sehe, dann. Ok, nee,
keine Ahnung. Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Ich habe es gerade bei Amazon gesucht. Ich habe
es nicht mehr gefunden. Aber gerade beim Pilsen hast du Riesen Glück. Das ist eine der angesagten
Sprachen überhaupt zur Zeit. Also du findest überall was. Und du findest garantiert auch
gute Buch Reviews, wo du da was raussuchen kannst. Und gerade für AI Geschichten, weil
das sowas neu ist und im Trend ist, da sind bestimmt auch YouTube Tutorials nicht schlecht
und im Zweifelsfall kann man sich auch irgendeinen Judemi Kurs angucken. Man darf sich da bloß
nicht verarschen lassen, dass man jetzt Geld spart. Sonst 200 Euro kosten jetzt nur 15
Euro. Die Kurse sind immer reduziert. Ich glaube, ich habe es noch nie gesehen bei Judemi
und diesen anderen Plattformen, dass die Kurse nicht reduziert sind. Ist das so, Michael?
Ja gut, wahrscheinlich muss ich nachdenken. Wahrscheinlich muss ich nachdenken, weil ich
sage ansonsten, ansonsten sitze ich einfach da so BÄÄÄM IN YOUR FACE. Aber wenn ich
halt was auch sinnvolles erzählen muss, muss ich halt nachdenken, weil... Vor drei Jahren.
Okay, wenn man vor drei Jahren noch HTML auf Papier programmieren muss, ist das das
bitter für die Schule hier. Strukturprogramme ist für Programmierer, was das OSI-Modell
für Admin ist. Ne, das OSI-Modell hat noch einen gewissen Sinn und das ist auch nichts,
was man von Hand malen muss. Sondern das OSI-Modell ist insofern ganz sinnvoll, dass man überhaupt
erstmal checkt, dass es verschiedene Abstraktionsebenen gibt und gerade im Zusammenhang mit, warum
es auch gerade einen Switch gibt, einen Router gibt, warum es so unterschiedliche Netzwerkgeräte
gibt, warum es nicht ein Gerät gibt, was das alles macht. Und wenn es das gibt, dann ist
es ein Multifunktionsgerät, was einfach mehrere Sachen drin hat. Dafür ist das OSI-Modell
zu lernen, nicht verkehrt. Im Alltag denkt kein Mensch an das OSI-Modell, ja. Aber Strukturprogramme
sind von Anfang an Bullshit. UML, UML ist auch so ein Ding, wo die ganzen, wo die ganzen
Java-Object-Oriented-Leute übelst sich ein drauf, voll ein drauf abgeht, ja. Soll ich
mal sagen, wieviel UML-Diagramme ich schon gemalt hab? Ich mein, ich bin jetzt auch
nicht als Entwickler angestellt, ja. Aber trotzdem, was meint ihr, wieviel UML-Struktur-Diagramme
ich schon gemalt hab? Ne, Null sind es nicht, es sind schon mehr als Null. Kann man sagen,
zwei. Zwei Stück hab ich bisher gemalt. Einmal irgendwann in der Schule und einmal, wo ich
gedacht hab, hey, das ist jetzt ganz schön kompliziert, da blickst du nicht durch, ähm,
all dein Zeug vorher mal auf und ich hab festgestellt, es sucked. Und seither hab ich nie wieder
was gemacht. Supportic schreibt, ich musste in der ersten und zweiten Semester C++ auf
Papier schreiben. Das sind ja zwei Sachen, die sind hochgradig onKS. Erstens, programmieren
auf Papier und zweitens, C++. Bin Humanmediziner, der programmiert. Tja, das ist doch gut,
dass man auch Leute gibt, die von dem, was da programmiert werden, eine Ahnung haben,
was man damit macht am Ende. Ein Kumpel von mir hat Bioinformatik studiert. Konnt ich
mir auch einfach echt nichts drunter vorstellen. Ja. Aber es gibt schon teilweise Querverbindungen
heute, da kommt man gar nicht so drauf auf den ersten Blick. Ähm, Nazana, ich hab's
nicht übersprungen. Ich glaube, ich bin einer der wenigen Fachinformatiker Systemintegrationen,
die in der Abschlussprüfung strukturierte Verkabelung gestrichen haben und dafür die
Programmieraufgaben gemacht haben. Ich bin mit dem Chat ein bisschen hinten dran. Muss
den Chat erst noch aufholen. Ja, neu ist das, der Mensch schlaft gut, ich geh auch gleich.
Muss noch mal kacken. Dann muss ich pennen. Aber vielleicht streame ich morgen Mittag
gleich wieder, weil ich bin morgen 13.30, fahre ich heim von der Arbeit und dann bin
ich ja relativ früh da. Das ist nicht Pro-Com in der Stato-Seite.
Hast du schon mal was in Verbindung mit SPS programmiert? Hat, glaube ich, letztens schon
mal einer gefragt. Ich hab damals schon gesagt, was ist SPS und ich hab's schon wieder vergessen.
Also, nee. Ja, ab Schicht fünf interessiert dich auch nichts. Was sich beim OSI-Modell interessiert
ist zwei, drei und vier.
Ich glaube, ich hab den Chat gleich aufgeholt.
Studium-Talk, ich kann mir keinen Studium-Talk machen, ich hab mich studiert. Kann ich schlecht
drüber talken, oder? Kennst du Subway-Software? Oh ja, kenn ich. Kennt jemand noch Daily-WTF?
Das ist das Blog. Früher hab ich mal gelesen, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es das noch gibt.
Und wie ist Deepin bisher die beste Distribution für Noobs, die wir getestet haben? Ohne Scheiß
gefällt mir wirklich gut. Ich werd's nicht verwenden, aber ich find's gut.
J-Niklas, zwei, drei Monate. Dankeschön für den Sub. IQ steigt wieder hier. Will als
Abschlussprojekt ein IT-Asset-Management-Tool aufsetzen? Willst du das programmieren oder
willst du das aufsetzen? Äh, ja, vergiss. Ähm, auf... Ich hab noch kein gescheites
Tool gesehen, ehrlich gesagt. Das ist alles so Ultra-Business-Enterprise-Crap, den keiner
gerne bedient. Ja, wieviel Spy wäre? Gut, gut, gut. Wir machen mal besser aus, ja. Dann
weiß er nie, was das im Hintergrund so treibt. Wahrscheinlich Brute Force, gerade mal Netzwerklaufwerk-Passwort.
So, ich hab den Chat aufgeholt. Perfekt. Die Bilder im Reap... Oh, ich guck da gar
nicht rein. Ich guck da gar nicht rein. Dann lass ich den Sebaro und, äh, seine Freunde
machen, was sie wollen, ja. In den Reap-Channel im Discord guck ich nicht rein, ne. Vor allem,
ich hab mal den Fehler gemacht. Ich hab den Discord manchmal auf auf der Arbeit, um zu
gucken, ob was Neues geschrieben wird, wenn ich grad mal ein bisschen Zeit hab. Ähm,
ich hab einmal aus Versehen, äh, den Reap-Spam-Ordner aufgemacht, ja. Hab ich direkt noch, bevor
es fertig geladen ist, Steuerung W, Browser-Tab zugemacht, weil ich weiß, was passiert,
wenn das Ding fertig geladen wär. Äh, was heißt was passiert, was man dann da sieht.
Discord im Browser ist doch gut. Das ist schön an Discord. Okay, ist der Friseur noch
am Start, Leute? Müssen wir mal gucken. Ist der Friseur noch am Start? What the fuck?
Was? Also, ich weiß, dass er das immer spielt, aber. Mobile, Mobile Game Stream. Ach, Mist,
ich bin nicht eingeloggt. Der Friseur, da ist er. Oh, Mann, ja. Ja, der Friseur, der
Horst war jetzt. Okay, jetzt alles. Remax, Friseur. Also, man könnte das tatsächlich
spielen. Man könnte das auch sein lassen. Ich habe relativ vieler. Okay, also wir raiden
jetzt den Friseur. Zack. Also, Leute. Wir sehen uns dann. Was ist denn? CU. Fit is free
to play.